so leute ich bin auch mal wieder da zur abwechslung habe ich eigentlich die kategorie umgestellt
ich muss mal kurz gucken ob aber schon ja jaja es ist Scientology als kategorie zu irgendwelchen
gründen ist meine mein browser jetzt auf wissenschaft und technik umgesprungen von englisch
auf deutsch keine ahnung weshalb vielleicht ist meinem chrome aufgefallen geolocation ist
germany oder so keine ahnung das ist eh so ein buch mit sieben sigeln was da genau passiert im
hintergrund ihr müsst wahrscheinlich noch alle arbeiten ich habe glück ich bin seit dienstag
krank ich muss nicht arbeiten aber ich hatte mega husten der leute das hat was hatte ich
noch nie also so schlimme husten glaube ich noch nie in meinem leben es war komplett abartig
ich habe so ein inhalations ding bekommen aber das hatte ich auch noch nicht vorher
ach ja jetzt hat twitch mitbekommen dass der stream online ist hat er nicht so hat gar nicht so
lange gedauert 1 40 diesmal august leute so und ich muss jetzt in bonbon futtern und ich
habe was zu trinken hier also ihr müsst mich immer regelmäßig dran erinnern dass ich trinke und
dass ich dass ich abends über bonbons lutschen weil hals ist immer noch nicht gut leute ich sag
euch jetzt wo ihr da seid kann sich ja mal kann sich ja mal kurz erzählen ich habe seit letzter
woche schon seit letzter woche so karn und dienstag haben habe ich schon die ganze zeit gemerkt
irgendwie dass ich dass ich kratzen im hals hab husten nix wildes nix ist auch kein korn als
kein korona es ist kein korona das haben das haben wir geguckt es ist kein korona zumindest
habe ich habe nichts bei gedacht hat gut irgendwas irgendwas geholt sonst ihr habt ja auch gehört
dass in letzter zeit total oft auch schon gehustet habe und alles und ich habe ich bin jetzt doch
mal zum arzt gegangen ich habe gedacht das kann es ja nicht sein und er hat mich abgehört meinte
irgendwie es ist korona oder ich bin gegen irgendwas allergisch habe ich gesagt okay was ist für eine
mischung hat mich halt abgehört dann die aber korona war es nicht bei mir ist kein korona
zumindest zumindest ist auch schon wieder besser ja gut vielleicht das ist doch korona keine ahnung
das ist nicht schlecht danke für den sub und zumindest ich war dann da ungehekt auch auch
dir 13 monate huge goldkeks ponga subscription also ich weiß ich ich weiß nicht was da was was
genau ist zumindest hat er mir so was aufgeschrieben das habe ich bei der apotheke auch geholt das ist
so ein inhalations ding ist quasi das was man auch bekommt denke ich mal wenn man asthma hat
oder sowas bloß halt andere füllung halt so ein ding was man sich im mund schiebt und dann so
draufdrücken kann er ging ganz nah auf einmal kann ich sein zumindest ey leute ich sage euch ich
habe so was noch ist es ist es nee nee irgendwas anderes irgendwas mit wendt irgendwas leer wendt
wendt leer oder sowas nicht wendler ich glaube was heißt irgendwas mit wendt leer also nichts
für den mir zu tun wenn leer irgendwie sowas ja irgendwie so in der richtung in der richtung
ich muss mal gucken wie das heißt und ich habe das das erste mal genommen und das haut echt
rein das zeug ja ich bin das über ich ich habe keine ahnung ob das welche bauform das ist das
ist unitaliener steckst den mond dann drückte drauf und das kostet erst mal überwindung das
einzuatmen und da wird es einem schon ein bisschen schwindelig bei das haut das haut echt rein das
zeug wie gesagt muss ich noch ein bisschen deswegen muss ich jetzt auch mal bauern fuddern aber ich
habe mir gedacht anstatt die ganze tage nur rumzulegen und nichts zu machen oder ein bisschen am rechter
zu hocken dann eine runde streemsohn extreme der dankeschön für den sub und zwar mal heute ein
bisschen frontend stells wieder einfach weil das was ist was mich zur zeit interessiert
hätte ich auch nie gedacht dass ich mich mal für jasus krippen geturnt installieren
auf keinen fall nein habe ich noch nicht habe ich noch nicht so was ist denn soll ich als warum
gibt es 30 milliarden java script freien wir reactiv ja moment moment heißt das es gibt noch
noch mehr neues zeug oder was also react reicht nicht angular reicht nicht view reicht nicht
es welt reicht nicht sonst was reicht reicht alle brauchen noch mehr braucht noch noch mehr das
gute an react ich habe nie recht verwendet leute das habe ich schon oft gesagt ich habe da keine
ahnung von aber ich glaube eines der riesen vorteile von react ist eben selbst wenn es probleme hat dass
es einfach verbreitet wie sau ist du findest libraries gut support für alles mögliche du
findest tutorials für alles möglich konferenzen web talks es ist kann ich euch aus eigener erfahrung
jetzt über die letzten jahre sagen ich programmiert auch schon über 20 jahre manchmal manchmal ist es
nicht so sehr was so diese dass die kern features hergeben sondern auch das ökosystem drum herum
also sprich das ist das gleiche so ein bisschen wie mit node.js und deno ich weiß nicht kennt
kennt ihr deno deno das da das ist ein bisschen das ist ein bisschen wie mit node.js und deno
finde ich finde ich jetzt so das mag ja sein dass deno node.js in vielen bild ich kann ich nicht
beurteilen ich kenne das auch nur als webcast ich habe selbst noch nie verwendet verwendet aber es
mag ja sein dass deno irgendwie node in gewissen bereichen überlegen ist meinetwegen aber ich
sage dazu nur npm packages es gibt published ich hätte eine komplette node ich dachte eigentlich
da steht jetzt irgendwie mal eine anzahl an insgesamt packages haben die haben die statistics
status npm.js statistics haben die statistics p.m. trends keine ahnung zumindest was ich halt was
ich worauf ich eigentlich raus will ist es ist ja schön und gut wenn somit die kerntechnologie
vielleicht vorteile hat gegenüber einer anderen aber bei node machen es einfach die 30 billarden
pakete und libraries die es dafür gibt und das ist bei vielen sachen so also das ökosystem drum
herum ist genau wie craftql rest ablösen wird was ja auch blödsinn gibt durchaus genug dinger die
sind sinnvoll mit stink normalem get push und put und delete und was auch immer zu machen und ohne
craftql craftql hat seine gucken wir uns ja heute auch an craftql hat seine vorteile eine beispiele
zwar sachen subscriben willst oder filtern willst oder sortieren willst oder pagen willst oder so da
ist das alles ganz nice da musst du vieles nicht selbst machen aber für den publishes user hat
einen knopf gedrückt brauchst kein craft ql ja gut das ist auch über z plus plus z plus plus
aber z plus plus sagt man ja auch immer nach dem motto es gibt jetzt technologie xy löst z plus
plus ab und ist da nicht so dass ich auch schwasse nicht z plus plus wird nie jemand ablösen egal wie
scheiß es ist ja ich mache mal kurz meine vm an wir müssen mal updaten haben wir schon eine
weile nicht mal angehabt ja also was wir heute machen ist folgendes wir versuchen ich habe mir
ich habe mir überlegt was wir versuchen programmierdinger machen können glocks
langische für den sub 27 monate huge hyper subscription aber der desktop ist der beste
weiß gar nicht was sie gegen das jedes mal wenn ich diesen desktop zeigt sagen die lauter max da
findet man gar nichts drauf aber ich habe euch jetzt schon oft genug gechallenged den chat sagt
mir was ich finden soll und ich finde es und ich habe es immer gefunden easy
bezüglich frameworks das wurde mir auch empfohlen habe ich noch nicht geguckt
übrigens ich habe einen ziemlich guten konferenztag letztens gesehen auf youtube
alles ndc conference das sah ne das nicht so lang ja den gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an
habe ich am letzten ziemlich guten konferenztag gesehen und da waren ein paar äußerst interessante
dinger drinne für character encoding und weil man sich manchmal fragt woher kommt der ganze scheiß
zum beispiel woher kommt kontrol c unter linux immer noch und sowas fand ich echt nicht schlecht
ich habe nicht recycelt ich finde kraftquel ist gar nicht mal so kompliziert wenn man halt
gemerkt keine mit wie heißt das mutations verwendet ich finde kraftquel ist super für
queries und wenn man bild in sachen wie sortieren und filtern verwenden kann die die jeweiligen
surfer haben oder für subscriptions mutations finde ich sacken richtig krass über kraftquel
zum querien finde ich kraftquel richtig geil bis abscretion ist auch aber für für den rest
weiß ich ist mir rest lieber so ich wollte ja mein mein nilux update das war mir alles zu
ab normal termination ja ok dann terminieren wir ab normal alles klar ist das russland nee das war
jetzt keine absicht ich habe kein bock dass wir irgendwelche politischen dinger machen es
geht mir schon überall auf den sack jeder jeder weiß es besser und ist super schlau
so wir machen erst mal update von den packages die leute waren ja schon über meinen tweet von
gestern mega getriggert wieder ja ich würde da geschrieben ich kann die ich kann die panzer
nicht auseinander halten die man auf den fotos sieht weiße durch durch die games habe ich nur
gelernt wie ami panzer aussehen wie russen panzer aussehen aber was ich nicht auseinander halten
kann ist russen panzer versus russen panzer da blicke ich auf fotos nicht durch wer wer ist
oder das habe ich ernst gemeint ich habe wirklich nicht durch ich habe ich habe gestern das subreddit
gelesen das ukraine subreddit und ich habe mir bilder angeguckt das bilder gab von kaputten
panzern und die sahen alle gleich aus ich habe keine ahnung gab was das war und die leute waren
schon wieder ins getriggert max das ist kein spaß also der ach nee ich mein es ja auch ernst
ich habe wirklich keine ahnung was man da sieht die blicken da selbst nicht das wird mich nicht
wundern so erst mal updaten den ganzen schitt ja leute sind heute wegen wirklich allem instant
getriggert die haben die panzer mit weißer farbe markiert ja gut manchmal wenn wenn wenn
elektronischer feifert kramlich funktioniert muss man auf klassische klassisch bewährte
metoden zurückgreifen die leute entwickeln heute noch was mit c++ weil ich das nicht als bewährt
sehen würde als weiße farbe sicherlich bewährter ich hoffe mal es laufen dort keine panzer und
sachen in c++ dann ist er vorbei noch schlimmer java script ja nee muss deswegen ich habe da
eigentlich auch gar kein bock drauf groß was hat groß was dazu zu erzählen es gibt keinen
skinshop ja hey max kann ich bei dem traffic docker compose setup subdomens auch auf andere
ip weiterleiten ja kannst du machen aber die traffic konfig ist halt mega beschissen also
ganz ehrlich traffic ist nice solang du automatische discovery geschichten verwenden kannst zum
beispiel das ist ein docker container automatisch erkennt dann ist traffic nice traffic konfig
von hand ist scheiße die ist wirklich hässlich und deswegen wenn du hauptsächlich reverse
proxy machen willst für quasi beliebige subdomens auf andere ip weiterleiten dann würde
ich dir tatsächlich entweder einen caddy empfehlen wenn du es von hand machen willst oder den
engine x proxy manager engine x proxy manager kannst du auch als docker container laufen
lassen aber da klickst du halt einfach im GUI was du haben willst und wohin es soll
was ich einfacher finde traffic konfig von hand ist wirklich panes champ so hat das jetzt
geupdatet alles hier nice ja auch nochmal alle anderen packages updaten jawoll ne das
vorbei die sind dieses compiler ding brauchen wir nicht mehr erstmal erstmal entfernen
update zack so und was ich mir für die streams gedacht habe ist folgendes immer wenn man
so ein bisschen bastel streams mal also programmier sachen geht es nicht basteln wie wie an der
android kiste oder so ich habe mir überlegt was ganz gut wäre ist wenn man das irgendwie
immer in ein wie soll ich das nennen so halbwegs realistisches sind also sonst möglich ist
so in ein halbwegs realistisches scenario einbettet zum beispiel habe ich mir überlegt
also was ich mir die ganze zeit schon mal angucken wollte ist welt und craft ql zusammen
habe ich noch nicht gemacht ne ne ich ich mache eine super simple eigene die eigentlich
nix hat außer vielleicht ein query und ein eine subscription oder so was ich mache da
mache eine eigene und genau gut dass du fragst weil jetzt bin ich bin ich ja gerade dabei
zum erzählen und ich habe mir gedacht wir machen einfach ein fake monitoring system
dass halt sachen ausgibt wie service war realistisch so was will ich jetzt öfters machen halt
sachen die irgendwie der halbwegs noch an die realität rankommen wir bauen einfach
ein fake monitoring system was monitoring meldung generiert keine ahnung kritisch festplatte
ist voll oder irgendwie sowas was was random monitoring meldung generiert und per craft
ql subscription zum client schickt irgendwie sowas und dann dann können wir dann irgendwie
auch eine schöne schönes dashboard machen wo man sich das anzeigen kann oder so weil
ich will ja ich will ja eh ein bisschen mehr frontend zeug lernen insofern dass ich wenigstens
ein bisschen durchblicke weil man muss ehrlich sagen gerade was das thema css angeht javascript
an sich ist gar nicht mal für mich das problem das kriege ich mittlerweile eigentlich ganz
brauchbar hin ich bin zwar nicht komplett up to date was so super moderne geschichten
angehen zum beispiel habe ich bis heute nicht so genau verstanden was das hier zum beispiel
macht ich glaube das entpackt das data property von einem objekt in in der eigene variabla
oder irgendwie sowas keine ahnung ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden was das genau macht
aber zum größten teil also im größten teil blick ich javascript sachen eigentlich mittlerweile
schon ganz gut durch html gut html gibt es nicht so viel zum durchblicken da könnte
ich aber auch besser durchblicken aber wo ich überhaupt nicht durch blicken ist css
leute css und und design geschichten ohne scheiß ich blicke nicht durch css css ist
so ein ding ich mache ich mache teilweise noch wenn ich anstatt das also nur um zu erklären
wie schlimm das bei mir ist ich habe noch vor ein paar monaten anstatt margin top margin
bottom und sowas zu verwenden habe ich breaks zwischen den dingern gemacht ja also da blicke
ich überhaupt nicht durch und wo es komplett aufhört wo es komplett wo es komplett bei
mir aufhört ist krit mit automatischen columns und sowas da ist vorbei da ist wirklich durch
da blicke ich gar nicht das kriege ich nicht hin ja und wo ich auch kein allzu gutes händchen
für habe muss ich sagen ist farbauswahl und sowas deswegen wir basteln heute mal ein bisschen
so wir machen erstmal ein update für die ganzen jet-brains-dinger
ach mist ich habe mir immer noch nicht mein lizenzcode hier rüber kopiert und das ding
aktiviert ich hoffe nicht dass mein fake account ausgelaufen ist mit dem ich mich letztens registriert
habe oh nee please kann man die lizenz nicht kopieren kann ich nicht die lizenz kopieren
von weil hier hatte ich es mal aktiviert ich hatte ich hatte mein rider hier mal aktiviert
das ist noch uralt kann man den lizenz kann man nicht einfach den lizenz feil rüber kopieren
oder sowas von dem ein rider ins andere da ist die lizenz ja drin für farben gehe einfach
auf kohler was coolers nee was kohlers.co nein da gehe ich nicht hin die seite gibt es
nicht was macht das was ist das was tut es es kommt glaube ich in meinem adblock nicht
klar kannst du mal sagen was wir machen wir probieren eine oh wie sag ich das jetzt kurz
wir bauen eine eine web anwendung mit swell plus craftql um keine ahnung automatische
updates im client anzuzeigen wir bauen so ein fake monitoring system als beispiel was
was gar nichts monitor was einfach nur meldung verschickt ist ist wieder falsch ja was denn
was soll ich jetzt hier ok ich google jetzt danach kohlers co ist doch richtig hier das
da oder sorry restart firefox das da ausschließlich ausschließlich mit css gemacht zeigt mal was
es ausschließt boah das ist ja krass guckt mal leute aus also wenn das wirklich stimmt
ausschließlich mit css gemacht wie macht man dann sowas mit css animationen oder wie
ist es nicht schlecht high iq auf jeden fall tatsächlich nur mit css gemacht ok ist natürlich
nicht interaktiv weil es nur css ist ach du scheiße alter ist das ist das echtes 3d
oder fake 3d was zum was passiert hier überhaupt warte mal das muss wir meinen browser mit
mit 3d beschleunigung angucken ob es dann weniger ruckelt ja komm mal das läuft super
flüssig jetzt vor krass ich versuche gar nicht zu verstehen wie es funktioniert richtig
feifert es ist fake 3d aber trotzdem nicht schlecht krasser scheiß nur mit css echt
nicht übel extrem poc war das alles geupdatet ist rider 2022 nicht schon was raus ne oder
anscheinend nicht von dem video beide wehe ok ok meine lizenz ist noch nicht abgelaufen
sehr gut sehr gut so also so wir haben alles geupdatet ich weiß dann ob ich noch neu starten
soll ok leute was hä was ist das was ihr mir hier geschickt habt super fast color palette
generator oder pallets generator ach so der generiert ihr fünf farben die gut zueinander
passen das macht den dark mode aus hast recht ja der generiert die farben die gut zueinander
passen oder wie kann er auch dark sims generieren kann er auch kann er auch hierzu jetzt ein
passendes dark sim generieren oder light sim oder sonst was oder oder kann man die gut
in wörten und ist nicht das nicht das nicht übel ist tatsächlich ganz nett aber schauen
wir mal so repos wir legen da ein neues projekt an ach so welche dort net version habe ich
eigentlich version 6.0 so und ich muss nebenbei mal mein lokales github auf machen geht nicht
github mein lokales github auf machen dass ich ein bisschen spicken kann aus anderen
projekten wo ich schon mal craftql in dotnet eingebaut habe weil aus dem kopf weiß ich
das auch nicht alles aber das finde ich gut also das hier ist schön eine sache die ich
bei tailwind mag die ich bei tailwind zu schätzen gelernt habe ist man kann view shades machen
also was ich bei tailwind zu schätzen gelernt habe ist weil ich absolut css kack noob bin
ja also ich habe kein gefühl richtig für farben die zusammen passen und ich habe kein
gefühl dafür wie man wie man richtige sachen in css so kombiniert dass es rauskommt was
ich haben will man könnte jetzt natürlich sagen tailwind ist ja noch mal ein extra layer
damit lernst du css auch nicht richtig mag sein mag sein aber was ich da eigentlich ganz
gut finde ist die haben standardmäßig farben drin mit unterschiedlichsten abstufungen die
ganz gut miteinander harmonieren das macht es für mich zumindest ein bisschen einfacher
so auf geht's wir legen jetzt mal ein projekt an wir machen ein minimal api habe ich mir
gedacht das ist neu in dort net weiß ich ob das schon jemand von euch mal verwendet hat
man kann in dort net jetzt ein bisschen so was machen wie beispielsweise in pyson das
schon länger geht somit weiß ich was es in pyson alles gibt so flask und so dinger dass
man quasi drei zeilen web anwendungen machen kann das geht jetzt das geht jetzt auch das
ist alles was man dafür braucht um eine dort net web anwendung zu erstellen die vier zeilen
und seit dort net fünf glaube ich dass es dort net fünf ist braucht man noch nicht mal
mehr dieses ganze program main und sonstige sonstigen müll probieren es jetzt mal aus
new solution core web application wie nennt man das jetzt was muss ich dafür eigentlich
auswählen web web app nee ich glaube kann es sein dass ich das mit den kommando zeilen
generieren muss dort net new web ok aber man das hier aber das hier mk dir genau svelte
fql irgendwie dass ich wieder finde dort net new web was hältst du eigentlich von blazer
ich habe heute morgen witzigerweise in den aktuellen konferenz vortrag dazu angefangen
zu gucken aber erst ich bin erst zehn minuten drin also was ich bisher von also ich kann
immer sagen was ich warum ich bisher blazer nicht gemocht habe oder nicht so großer fan
davon war obwohl ihr wisst dass ich sie scharf eigentlich mag also eigentlich ist blazer
wie gemacht für mich blazer ist wer das nicht kennt ist der versuch von microsoft dort net
im browser lauffähig zu machen da kann man dann solche sachen hier drinnen machen guckt
ob es irgendwie ein beispiel beispiel ja sowas kannst du dann hier machen also kannst dann
quasi das hier läuft im browser also du kannst dann quasi im browser sie scharf verwenden
das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich gute idee und theoretisch so als dort net sie scharf
hin müsste das eigentlich so mein mein feuchter gachibus traum sein so und warum ich warum
ich blazer bisher nicht gemocht habe sind zwei sachen erstens war die in war der interop
mit javascript was du nach wie vor an vielen stellen gebraucht hast als ich das letzte
mal ausprobiert habe nicht so schön und das zweite war der download war wahnsinnig groß
also du musstest erstmal irgendwie 12 mb oder so runterladen zusätzlich und dann musste
das ganze quasi noch ich nenne zwar naja buten kann man es nicht nennen aber dann musste
die runtime erst mal starten also blazer war langsam im download und langsam im start also
sprich die seiten haben wir irgendwie zwei drei sekunden gedauert bis sie überhaupt
richtig richtig nach dem ersten aufruf funktioniert haben so das ist das warum mir das ganze nicht
so gefallen hat und es war kein dort net sondern es war am anfang noch mono unten drunter das
fand ich auch nicht so schön das ist die geschichte mir an blazer nicht gefallen hat aber es hat
sich da in den letzten zwei drei jahren sicherlich viel getan und einiges ist davon schon gar
nicht mehr so ja trinken wichtig uns über den hals ok da sind wir dann öffnen wir
das mal ein rider und gucken was wir da so auf die reihe kriegen ich würde sagen wir
fangen erst mal an mit einem mini frontend wo wir dann am endeffekt auf was drin anzeigen
können weil es hat ja keinen sinn wenn ich beckern technisch was basteln und im frontend
nichts angezeigt hört also dann sehe ich ja gar nicht ob es funktioniert wie öffnet man
hier irgendwas drinnen repos das home max repos fql jawoll ok trust ich truste michel
natürlich leute also es gibt irgendjemand der microsoft sache nicht trusten würde trusten
sofort alles trusted ich habe mir sogar von bildi 5g antenne impfen lassen also überhaupt
kein problem so guckt mal leute das ist alles was man aktuell für eine minimal api webanwendung
in sichar braucht euch fällt vielleicht auf das ist aber schon seit dotnet 5 so dass es
kein übliches program mehr braucht man kann jetzt seine programme zumindest an einer stelle
ohne klasse und alles drum herum schreiben main ist plaudit also diese zeilen reichen
dafür dass wir eine dort net dort net run dass wir eine minimale dort net web anwendung
haben ich kann euch auch zeigen dass es funktioniert lokal host was haben wir hier 5133 bm hello
world kommt zurück das ist das standard template und das ist wirklich das kleinste wie das
mittlerweile funktioniert was ziemlich cool ist wenn man das vergleicht mit einer standard
asp.net mvc oder web api geschichte die ist deutlich umfangreicher und ich finde auch
nicht gerade viel klarer das finde ich eine gute idee sieht fast eins zu eins aus wie express
ja ich glaube auch dass express den ihr vorbild war was das angeht wobei man halt sagen muss
diese ganzen mini framework sehen so ähnlich aus kennt noch einer ruby kennt das noch einer
weiß ich ob das jemand mal ruby verwendet hat das war so beschissene farben kann man
nicht nehmen das war so eines der ersten micro web frameworks überhaupt da konnte man auch
so sachen hier machen die seien 10 von 10 ja die bildet hintergrund ja ok so ja wir machen
jetzt aber gar kein gar kein backend gedöns wir legen jetzt mal eine anwendung an repos
weltcraft ql so wie legt man jetzt noch mal das welt kit anwendung an npx npx wir haben
das doch bestimmt noch irgendwo in it ah hier guck mal da npm innens weltnext frontend von
den jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder kram heißen soll ja das heißt einfach frontend passt
auch ist ok yes proceed skeleton project typescript no lind als als ob prettier null was ist was
ist playwright was ist playwright irgendwas zum testen ist das so was wie pappetier oder
sowas ist das so selenium pappetier mäßig oder was ist example docks example wisst ihr
was ich immer doof finde wenn es die brauchen hier das finde ich gut ich bin immer gut wenn
die so ein mini example dass du gleich weißt was du dich da einlässt ok test basic test
async page das ist das ist das basiert bestimmt auf pappetier oder so kann ich mir vorstellen
ok das ist ein testing framework mit browser fernsteuerung drin alles klar na gut so nein
das brauchen wir nicht alles klar cd frontend npm install und jetzt müssen wir was machen
open so dann können wir anfangen da bin ich ja mal gespannt ob ich das mit craft kill
auf die reihe krieg test testen tun wir prinzipiell nicht erkennt mich wir müssen zwei sachen
nicht machen und das ist dokumentieren und testen ja weil erstens guter code dokumentiert
sich selbst und zweitens wenn man nix kaputt macht gibt es keine fehler man muss auch nix
testen ist eigentlich ganz klar chillfreak danke für den sub cringe wer testet ja genau
und dann noch schlimmer wenn die leute anfangen mit tdd oder sowas ne da fangen wir gar nicht
erst mit an testen ist für noobs und wir möchten ja keine noobs sein so wie gehts
denn jetzt weiter so ich muss tailwind adden das weiß ich auch das kann ich mich noch dran
installen was war das ich versuchte es mir gerade irgendwie aus der history zusammenzuwursten
minus forms ging dann glaube ich oder yes hoffe das funst jetzt was ich hier so treibe alles
klar npm install so ok die front die backend geschichte schieben wir mal auf desktop 4
und ok jetzt mal wishlist studio code auf das schieben wir auf desktop 3 wir trusten
an allem natürlich was sonst index platform ja auch installieren ich brauche jetzt kein
arduino zeug ne ne wo ist denn mein index an index ok und jetzt muss man das ganze starten
open da sind wir nice auf geht's wishlist studio code oder jetbrain ide ist beides guck mal
da wishlist studio code für frontend jetbrains geht uns zur backend welches us hast du drauf
das ist manjaro mit i3 wm ich sollte dafür mal neo fetch oder ich habe neo fetch installiert
guck mal da kann ich jetzt immer immer neo fetch zeigen wenn einer fragt ach ja und daran
erkennt man auch dass es nur vms ich habe snaps installiert warum habe ich snaps snap
ich hatte mal dotnet und elixir kann ich alles löschen eigentlich snap wer macht freiwillig
snap ok sehr schön so dann können wir mal anfangen also den ganzen den ganzen krempel
brauchen wir nicht also jetzt jetzt äh bestaunt meine design skills ja also ich habe mir gedacht
was wir machen wir machen wir machen die website auf jeden fall schon mal im dark theme sind
wir uns glaube ich einig oder dark theme größer light theme warum windows als host und nicht
als vm naja weil die sache die ist linux unter windows lässt sich einfacher und besser virtualisieren
als windows unter linux gerade wenn man windows braucht für gaming video zeug und sonst was
also ich benutze windows für spielen ich benutze windows zum videos schneiden ich benutze windows
halt für 0815 sachen und wenn es um basteln und programmieren geht mache ich das unter
linux das ist so rum einfacher einfacher gibt ja genug leute die sagen ja warum macht
dann machst du denn keine vm mit gpu passthrough und sowas das hört sich nur in der theorie
gut an gpu passthrough mag ja eine coole sache sein aber spätestens wenn du dann das problem
hast dass du die grafika der eigentlich auch im haus bräuchtest weil du was sehen willst
auf deinem haus betriebssystem fängt schon an dass es komplizierter wird dann fangen
die leute an mit so komischen dingen wie looking class und sonst was rum zu experimentieren
dann kommt das nächste problem dass du deine maus direkt an windows durchreichen muss dass
das ordentlich funktioniert dass sie da drin was spielen kann sein hast du die maus auf
dem haus zwischen nicht mehr also das ist nicht schön wieso programmierst du nicht
unter windows mache ich auch haben wir auch schon teilweise aber seit rider gut funktioniert
also nennt muss ich muss ich alle sagen seit es rider gibt und die dort net entwicklung
auch gut unter linux funktioniert ist mir das aber ein vielfaches lieber weil weil linux
für mich einfach die bessere die angenehme entwicklungsumgebung ist das fängt schon
von von von der optik her dem package manager und dem terminal handling an da würde ich
anfälle kriegen unter windows sollte man jetzt auf windows 11 abdecken warum es sei
dann es sei dann es gibt irgendwas was du unbedingt haben willst was es nur unter windows
11 gibt wenn ich dann nicht so also wir machen dark sieben leute leute also ok class background
cray cray 900 guter background zack instant dark sieben ihr könnt die sonnenbrille abnehmen
leute flash bang zeit ist vorbei wir machen das jetzt alles alles dark dark gesiebt gut
schwarzer hintergrund man kann problemlos dort net unter linux entwickeln das hätte
ich nicht gehabt moment jade du hast das ist so man muss aber sagen dort net also dort
net core und dort net 5 und sowas ich will jetzt nicht von der dummen benahmung von microsoft
anfangen was du nicht unter linux gescheit entwickeln kannst ist das alte dort net framework
aber dort net framework ist eigentlich auch outdated overrated gebaited das braucht man
nicht mehr es gibt eigentlich nur noch dort net core und dort net core war quasi so geil
dass microsoft gedacht hat sie benennen es zur verwirrung aller mit dort net 5 um also
dort net 5 ist eigentlich dort net core 4.0 und dort net 4.0 also dort net 4.8 ist das
alte verstanden microsoft logik microsoft logik microsoft logik also ganz kurz ich
weil es immer wieder zur verwirrung kommt dort net framework das ist das alte das ist
windows only dann gab es mal eine neuentwicklung von microsoft die sich dort net core nannte
dort net core gab es von version 1 bis version 3 so und mit dort net 5 dort net 5 ist quasi
dort net core 4.0 man hat 4.0 übersprungen weil man angst davor hatte dass es die leute
confused mit 4.8 deswegen hat man das übersprungen hat man katas core weggelassen so und jetzt
aktuell sind wir bei dort net 6 was eigentlich dort net core 5 ist wenn man so in der alten
reinfolge weitergezählt hätte das ist aktuell und das ist cross platform das hat nichts
mit dem da zu tun das ist das in windows integrierte wer hat sich das ausgedacht die gleichen
leute die auch die benahmung der xbox verbrochen haben keine ahnung was beim microsoft los
ist richtig hängen geblieben auf jeden fall so also da sie schlimmer als usb ne ne ne
schlimmer als usb gehts glaube ich nicht in der richtung informatik ist es ein passwort
was du da hinten kopiert hast sieht fast aus würde als passwort durchgehen ne du hast
ein passwort auf der tastatur glaube ich ja wifi 6 revision 2 ist auch fail ok aber fangen
wir mal an huge designing skills leute huge huge designing skills also wisst ihr was
ich mir gedacht habe was wir machen wir machen also wir machen hier oben eine navigationsleiste
wobei wir brauchen eigentlich keine navigationsleiste weil wir haben nur eine seite wir machen trotzdem
eine navigationsleiste wir machen trotzdem eine navigationsleiste weil navigationsleisten
halt navigaten keine ahnung ohne ohne ohne ohne navigationsleiste ist doch auch blöd
so als baue mal eine navigationsleiste wie baut man eine schöne navigationsleiste ich
habe von design kein plan also wir wollen navigationsleiste erst mal überlegen man
muss ja die navigationsleiste sehen können das heißt die navigationsleiste muss schon
mal ein bisschen heller sein als mein hintergrund so da navigationsleiste achtung dann suchen
wir uns jetzt ein schönes emoji dann suchen wir jetzt ein schönes emoji als logo was ist
denn ein schönes emoji als logo für unsere unseren fake service der robot da hier kommt
er den robot da der kacke auf wir nehmen den robot da so zack haben wir sind emoji als
was habe ich denn hier für ein emoji font was ist das für ein emoji font ist das twitter
twitter emoji sekunde
was ist das für ein emoji font joy pixels ah es ist joy pixels ist mir auch wurscht
passt schon wir wollen jetzt wollen jetzt mal nicht an irgendwelchen emojis aufhängen
so also navigationsleiste navigationsleiste brauche brauche platz nach unten ne padding
brauche ich padding oder padding padding das ein bisschen größer wird boah alter mein
html stells kausam so padding text text white dass man was drauf erkennt so ok jetzt das
ist doch eine absolut augenweite navigationsleiste ok was kann man was kann man als nächstes
machen vorne machen wir erstmal unser unser icon hin unser logo vorne erstmal hin da
so und das ding bekommt klas text xl dass man das auch ein bisschen erkenne zwei mal
xl das ist das der robot da gefällt mir nicht in diesem emoji font aber etwas anderes ja
beste cute chat gut das ist unser logo größe passt glaube ich so und wie nennen wir wie
nennen wir das tool das cute das das cute heißt cute cute tool wunderbar das ist eigentlich
gar nicht schlecht die kombination und der name das könnte ich mir als echten service
irgendwo vorstellen ok so und da drin brauchen wir jetzt zwei zwei zwei zwei zwei links
so nennen wir das erste nennen wir mal kein overview so wie es beim nagios hieß warum
ist das jetzt untereinander und ich nebeneinander weil ich guck mal hier weil weil kein flex
so viel besser alter ist das ugly as fuck wie kriege ich das jetzt gescheit allein klas
muss ich center oder so selbst center hey poggers guck mal da und das da ist schon
die einzige person die was anderes macht als eldring ich habe es mir schon vorbestellt
auf steam und wahrscheinlich hat sogar vorhin schon runtergeladen aber ich werde das nicht
uns spielen so ok wunderbar weiter weiter im text also wir brauchen hier ein bisschen
abstand dazwischen macht man das so leute ich ich habe flexbox immer noch nicht gecheckt
wie mache ich jetzt ordentliche spacing hier dazwischen außer mit margin sondern wir wollen
kein diff wir wollen den link haben gucken dass es link ist dass man drauf klicken kann
gab x-4 oh guck mal da was das gab was macht das unter der column gab ne funktioniert nicht
oder muss ich das auf die auf die obere hier dazu machen gut zu wissen excellent excellent
das ist gut wie verhält sich das wenn ich ach guck mal ach jetzt trennt er die elemente
alle gleich auf oder das ist gut das ist gut kann ich dann auch das letzte item irgendwie
rechts machen das ist cool das ist gut das das finde ich finde ich nice das finde ich
aber finde ich nice so overview und jetzt keine ahnung eigentlich eigentlich brauche ich
kein ich nenne es einfach mal settings weil ich kann ich mache eigentlich kein zweiter
link ok so das muss jetzt natürlich noch ein bisschen schöner aussehen kann man das
roundt machen kann man das roundt machen roundt ist es jetzt roundt ne das geht an der stelle
nicht roundt roundt es ist jetzt roundt ne oder doch es ist roundt leute guck mal da
es ist roundt nice roundt so die schriftart gefällt mir noch nicht was gibt es da für
ne coole schriftart so aber das sieht das sieht noch nicht das sieht noch nicht so
nicht schön aus umschalt zum hellen them ja das könnte man dann rechts machen wenn
ich wüsste wie das funktioniert aber font der font könnte ein bisschen dicker sein
wir müssen ja markieren was wir gerade angeklickt haben font medium gibt es nicht font bold
kann man nur bottom roundt machen ja ja ja ich glaube schon man kann sagen roundt roundt
bottom bottom xl oder so guck mal da jetzt ist es nur unten nur unten roundt und oben
nicht roundt nur unten roundt sehr schön so und wir sind jetzt faul wir machen jetzt
einfach für das aktuelle tap machen wir unten drunter einen strich also wie machen wir
unten drunter einen strich border bottom two so so und dann sagen wir border irgendwie
das ganze blau oder 500 das sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht aus das sieht gar nicht mal
so mies aus oder das kann man erst mal lassen ok wunderbar lassen wir so ein hava effekt
hava effekt brauchen noch leute hava effekt muss auch noch sein ohne hava effekt gehen
wir gehen wir hier nicht gehen wir hier nicht raus ok das war nämlich so der hier ist text
gray gray ich will nicht dass man das gut sieht sagen 400 und jetzt und jetzt kommt
hier hava text white guck mal hier alter next level shit guckt euch das mal an ich meine
ich habe eine navigationsleiste ich habe nichts zum navigieren aber ich habe eine navigationsleiste
da ist alles in ordnung ok so und jetzt haben wir eine tabelle also wie gesagt ich ich baue
heute einen fake monitoring service der monitor nichts das back end schickt einfach nur meldungen
raus und das ganze soll dann per craft ql automatisch hier unten in irgendwie einer
hübschen tabelle angezeigt werden ziel ist craft ql und das welt zu üben sieht das sieht
in der tat gar nicht so beschissen aus hier das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut ok was kannst
du nicht beim nach die klasse item center einfügen bestimmt wie gesagt so css zeug ist nicht
meine expertise tatsächlich ja guck das funktioniert excellent wunderbar ok tabelle
tabelle wobei guck mal wir können sogar wir können dass die navigationsleiste können
sogar in layout machen dann ist sie nämlich auf jeder seite oben drüber so ist nämlich
index wieder leer so und jetzt haben wir eine tabelle wir machen einfach nur mal testweise
eine tabelle und mit die fette die füllen wir jetzt mit fake daten um zu gucken ob das
ob das funktioniert dazu geben wir mal tailwind table gucken uns mal ein paar beispiele an
tailwind table layout tailwind ui tables zeit mal her mal ein bisschen inspirieren lassen
table class table auto song sieht dann so aus so eins ganz ok muss man nur die farben
anpassen ok das ist viel zu sophisticated wobei das schon cool ist mit dem tag und so
hier hinten man könnte ja man könnte dann quasi anzeigen lassen ich weiß was wir machen
wir machen die hintergrundfarbe je nachdem was für eine fehlermeldung aufgetreten ist
also wenn es ein kritischer fehler ist dann machen wir die hintergrund dann lila wenn
es nur ein normaler fehler ist mal mit hintergrund rot oder sowas ja das probieren also machen
wir mal eine table das wird richtig wahnsinn einmal table table so funktioniert das schon
mal nicht table auto ok tape table hat also table muss ja erst mal eine farbe kriegen
table kriegt erst mal machen wir machen das hier mal weg also background grey zur 900
ist das also muss es auf jeden fall schon mal 800 sein dass man überhaupt gescheit
erkennt genau so als brauchen wir noch einen abstand zwischen der navigations leiste und
der tabelle also sagen wir mal margin bottom das habe ich vorhin glaube ich schon mir
irgendwas überlegt vier warum geht es nicht aha fünf wie kann man am besten in die javascript
welt einsteigen direkt mit angela view oder klassisch also zwischen welt und und dem zeug
ist jetzt von dem wie du es benutzt kein so großer unterschied welt ist zwar vom ansatz
her ein bisschen was anderes aber letztendlich von dem wie du es benutzt ist zwischen diesen
vier kein großer unterschied ich würde dir persönlich empfehlen weil das selbst bei mir
ist aber ich bin ja kein hauptberuflicher javascript entwickler oder sowas ich bastel
ja selbst nur ein bisschen mit rum und lernen das grad also ich persönlich fandet zum einstieg
view am angenehmsten damals da war es aber noch nicht so verwirrend mit view 2 sonntags
view 3 sonntags und sonst was für react hast du eindeutig die meisten tutorials meist
tutorials webcasts und alles und angular würde ich einen bogen drum machen also du bist enterprise
business entwickler aber natürlich wo man überhaupt nicht drumherum kommt ist ein bisschen
javascript zu lernen ich habe es mit in kombination mit future erst gelernt aber du kannst doch
irgendwas anderes nehmen für mich ist das schwierige eher nicht so das javascript sondern
hauptsächlich die ganze css geschichte dass es ordentlich ausschaut so also das haben
wir eine tabelle das schon mal so verkehrt wir wollen die schon mal komplett über die
ganze seite haben und die farbe stimmt ja auch nicht wir wollen text weit dass man was
sieht sondern sieht natürlich immer noch hardcore beschissen aus also lasst mal überlegen
table hat der so der header den machen wir ein bisschen heller damit man was sieht wobei
ja sieht aber immer noch kacke aus
las kann man sagen dass der text links ist ja schon mal besser immer noch kacke aus
ich brauche irgendwie so eine so eine margin oder ne leute wisst ihr was wir machen margin
um dir für für die ganze für das ganze body oder ist es margin oder padding ich kann
mir das immer nicht merken ist padding außenrum oder ist margin margin ist außenrum kam immer
nicht merken was da was davon ist es ganz ganz grausam padding oder ist es padding was
ist der unterschied zwischen margin und padding also margin 4 ist richtig in dem fall okay
so was in der richtung okay das sieht das sieht richtig das trägt hardcore beschissen
aus das muss ich anders machen so wir machen jetzt um die tabelle erst auch noch mal ein
bisschen margin dass man dass man wie kriege ich die tabelle größer padding kriege ich
jetzt dass da ein bisschen bisschen platz dazwischen ist wir machen wir machen den text
erst mal noch ein bisschen größer okay das ist doch schon mal gleich viel besser wenn
er wenn er wenn der überschriftstext fetter ist das finde ich schon mal gut
hau padding rein das ist eine gute idee also class oder sagen wir dem jetzt sagen wir dem jetzt mal keine ahnung padding top 2 okay das ist gut nice
poggers so muss das sein das sieht das sieht schon besser aus das ganze mache ich da unten
dann auch immer das dann nur eine rein das reicht also so also wir brauchen bisschen
test test daten also es ist nicht song artist und ja sondern ich baue ja so ein fake monitoring
system nach dashboard also das heißt im endeffekt wir haben dann so was wie start wann der alarm
aufgetreten ist wir haben den alarm an sich und keine ahnung so die quelle vom alarm
oder so was in der richtung so ok so dann haben wir dann haben wir da drin und dann
quasi ich mache jetzt mal fake mäßig irgendwas rein dann haben wir so was wie new date new
date alter java script und zeit wie ging das to local local string das ist halbwegs gescheit
aussieht ok so weil das halt auch kacke aussieht class muss ich dann auch sagen padding left
ok das das sieht doch jetzt gar nicht mal so kacke aus das sieht gar nicht so mies aus
das padding müsstest du in alle th text schreiben echt sonst sonst stimmt das nicht über ein wo
das anfängt oder ja guck mal das muss ich zumindest zumindest ja ja jetzt jetzt stimmt
genau das ist jetzt sonst sonst sind die dinge gar nicht richtig ganz ehrlich warum mache ich
nicht einfach padding 2 und gut ist so eigentlich viel besser oder anstatt sich einzeln einzeln zu
schreiben einfach so so test test alarm keine ahnung 95 prozent disk space oder so was so
und source ist das ist irgendein hausname source ist keine ahnung db punkt cute chat putney cute
punkt chat so in der richtung könnte man könnte man das machen ja aber das sieht gar nicht mal
so schlecht aus vielleicht noch ein bisschen wir müssten da eigentlich noch so einen border
drum machen das ist ein bisschen das ist so so nicht hübsch ist es immer noch nicht aber ich
glaube damit können wir erst damit können wir erstmal leben was wir noch ausprobieren
müssen was für farben nehmen weil mal angenommen das hier wäre eine kritische fehlermeldung dann
müsste das eigentlich bg was ist eine gute farbe für kritische für kritische fehlermeldung rot
oder die error error aber hier purple das ist übrigens auch alles nicht hoch genug hier
das müsste das muss auch noch das muss auch noch größer größer werden
ich sagen padding heading yln oder sowas drei wie geht das ey ja schon viel besser jetzt ist
das nicht so jetzt ist das nicht so gestaucht ok bg red 600 sagt ihr ja ist eigentlich ganz nice
was haltet ihr denn davon was haltet im moment wir gucken jetzt was tailwind colors was haben
wir denn jetzt so auswahl red orange also orange orange machen wir für warning blue indigo violet
fuchs ja das war als was wir mal als fuchs ja 600 leute das ist gar nicht mal so doof für
einen kritischen fehler finde ich jetzt es ist gar nicht mal so schlecht gut ich meine das muss
dann in alle rein das ist gar nicht übel die schrift ist noch ein bisschen klein das ist so
fatal error ok so aber das nächste das nächste ist dann 95 prozent oder wir machen hier das
nächste ist dann ein fehler aber es nicht kaputt kannst du nicht auch die bg ne hier kann man
glaube ich nicht die hintergrundfarbe machen im table row ne ich glaube das geht nicht wartet
mal wartet ich glaube das geht nicht kennst du ein gutes advance tutorial für craft ql nee ich
muss da immer ausgehen easy easy ja dann lassen wir das so lull warum sollte ich das dann so doppel
und dreifach machen so ist viel besser und der nächste fehler der ist jetzt der ist jetzt nur
nur nicht kritisch sondern normaler fehler und dann nehmen wir keine ahnung pink rot rosé rosé
600 rosé oui oui also class bg rosé 500 600 ich finde das nicht schlecht das ist das ist
echt ganz nice so und jetzt müssen wir noch die schriftgröße ein bisschen ein bisschen anpassen
ist die ist zu zu klein machen wir mal hier text text lg schon besser schon besser
schon besser ein bisschen größer das sieht gar nicht schlecht aus leute ich finde das ist
durchaus in ordnung wir müssen auch wir müssen die tabelle noch rounded machen leute table
rounded rounded ist sie jetzt rounded vielleicht kann man tabelle nicht rounded machen kann das
sein dass man tabelle nicht rounded rounden kann muss man extra difft rum machen muss man
dann difft rum machen dass man das rounded machen kann das rounded jetzt order hier oder so tatsächlich
man muss dann im difft rum machen was ist das warum muss man warum kann man die tabelle nicht
direkt rounded machen was das warum verstehe ich nicht auf alle danken für den sub na gut border
grey 800 das ist gar nicht mal so kacke das steht auf die artys sein ok kann ich mit leben das ok
das können wir so lassen so wir müssen aber die schrift die schrift hier noch ein bisschen die
schrift noch ein bisschen größer machen beziehungsweise ein bisschen dicker machen wir machen die die zeit
wann das anfängsamer font bolt so ist das schick so finde ich das gut und das hier könnte auch noch
ein bisschen dicker sein was gibt es dann noch font medium gibt es dann glaube ich noch der
funktioniert hier etwas kann meine schriftart nicht was soll es am ende werden einfach nur
was zum üben wir machen fake monitoring system also ich bastel den craftql backend was random
monitoring meldung schickt und das zeigen wir dann live in der tabelle an ich will einfach
gucken wie man denn wie man das macht das ist jetzt aktuell nur wie das wie es aussehen soll
wenn es funktioniert so eigentlich könnte man den border fast noch ein bisschen fetter machen oder
also man könnte eigentlich fast schon sein border acht falls es das gibt
heute wir machen das noch wir machen das wir machen hier oben wir lassen das wir lassen das
so ja so viel besser viel besser gut ich baue eine andere schrift art ist die zeit wichtiger
als der alert sonst müsste es doch andersrum sein ja die zeit ist tatsächlich insofern wichtig
weil sobald was was jetzt auftritt ist ja erst mal akut ja kann man sich drüber oh leute ich
sehe wir müssen es noch sortierbar machen später ai ai ai das wird das wird noch was sortable
denkt man müssen es sortierbar machen dann noch dass man da oben draufklicken kann so wir machen
jetzt 5 hat die sein choices noch tr hover ist nicht ist nicht das tr die der hätt der hätt hover
bg gray 700 guck mal war ja uns da kann man das später anklicken und dann so kann man das
sortieren wenn man hier reinklickt so weit von der idee her filter und curies ist also filter
ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schwierig mit craft ql zumindest das was ich verwende das hat
schon filter für so sachen wie größer kleiner enthält und so eingebaut ok nice wunderbar so das
reicht jetzt erst mal so kann man sich glaube ich ganz gut vorstellen wir brauchen noch eine
andere schrift art ich mag das nicht dass es hier so klein ist was ich eigentlich ganz gut finde
bei denen ist guck mal die haben ihr font weight so und die haben die möglichkeit dass du eigentlich
sagen kannst normal also ich habe das hier ist normal das ist mir aber zu dünn oder dass du
sagen kannst medium ich will eigentlich medium haben und nicht semi oder bold medium welche optimal
dafür weil bold ist zu dick und semi bold kann er wahrscheinlich nicht ist auch genauso wie bold
ubuntu font was haben die dann hier für einen font überhaupt wie kriege ich dann jetzt raus was
das für einen font ist gescheit inspekt computed font family oder sowas
von ks intervall intervall was ist denn was ist denn intervall für den intervall font
was von rasmus anderson alles klar den will ich auch haben dass er mehrere weights anbietet
perfekt ich will alle weights haben easy scheiß auf download größe keck weh sag alles rein da bäm
import gib ihm wir brauchen nur den import so import zack und jetzt können wir auch sagen
style style ach nee ich will das für die ganze anwendung ändern rasmus anderson by the way
einer der künder von notion aha ok ich weiß nicht was notion ist ist das irgendeine notiz app
oder wird einfach nur kurz gucken ob das funktioniert font family inter ne das funs leute guck mal der
font sieht richtig gut aus der font das sieht richtig gut aus mit dem font das gefällt mir
so wir machen das jetzt hier nicht bald wir machen das hier mal medium das war mal semi bold
das war medium ach nee ich bin ja auch blöd das falsche was ich hier mache so font medium ja
das ist cool das finde ich nice das sieht gar nicht schlecht aus grip wegen den google fonts
hä warum so projekt management oder habe ich zum glück nichts mögliches ok das sieht das
sieht ganz das sieht doch eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus nice gut so jetzt müssen wir gucken wie man
projekt management ja ganz schlimm das muss mal gucken wie man die daten reinkriegen
gibt es noch chat gibt sonst noch irgendwas was ich unbedingt unbedingt ändern muss an der optik
ich weiß jetzt kommt der chat und sagt max macht die seite noch mal neu oder so was ich glaube das
kann man schon so lassen das ist in ordnung google fonts weg wenn du die nicht selber haustest sind
die gegen der es ist mir scheiß egal zum für meine test ist das vollkommen irrelevant ob das
dsg ich mache euch gleich leute ich mache gleich in dsg v o banner hier unten hin so ne so ne accept
ja bei naf overview und settings etwas tiefer setzen ok mal gucken ob ich das hinkrieg
dann machen wir das nämlich so nicht item center sondern sagen
guck mal ne ne ne leute das sieht scheiße aus ich muss das wieder muss das sentern
recht da reichen die designer skills jetzt nicht ausführen das muss jetzt so bleiben
das bleibt jetzt so bis ich das raubt bis ich das out out gefigert habe ja wie das
funktioniert da setzen wir morgen noch ab ellenrahmen in light light light gray
du meinst dass wir den border quasi in etwas helleren ne das kacke aus
das bleibt jetzt so bevor wir uns jetzt damit damit zu lange aufhalten so also das ist von
der optik her finde ich in ordnung zum testen jetzt kommt die eigentliche knackpunkt wir
brauchen unser craft und irgendwo hier müssen wir jetzt die daten abrufen also script so
jetzt mal irgendwie fetsch oder so zum testen mal also von familie im moment ich will ich von
ich will das ja überall haben wie extend ich tailwind tailwind extent font wie kriege ich
zusätzlichen font da rein da haben die doch ein beispiel hier irgendwo gehabt hier guck mal da
tailwind konfig punkt js warum ist es eine tailwind konfig punkt cjs warum ist es warum
ist das hier js und das jetzt cc just gibt sagen die muss ich nicht verstehen extenders
leute ich muss ich muss ich muss euch was erzählen ich habe letztens auf youtube in
ein video geschaut wird mir empfohlen zufällig irgendwie ihr wisst ich gucke eigentlich so gut
wie nie animes und sowas also hier kein kein ultra wieb am start ja und da habe ich ein video
geguckt irgendwie was weiß ich must watch animes 2022 oder so und ich dachte mir so letztens ein
miss e langweilig gucken was ihr was er da drin hat da habe ich ein von ihm seine topless da
angemacht leute ich war zutiefst verstört wieder aber ich dachte es ist eine ganz normale fantasy
story und auf einmal ja was auch immer was auch immer super aber richtig so wo sie überstehen
goblins der slayer es war etwas mit m am anfang mo mo mo tensei oder sowas keine ahnung dabei
ich muss sagen ich habe mich habe jetzt irgendwie die ersten fünf sechs folgen eigentlich ist
gar nicht schlecht aber warum zwischenzeitlich immer irgendwelche perversen einlagen kommen
verstehe ich nicht genau neil zit genau das genau das du hast erkannt das ist das ja ja
das da das eigentlich ist es von der welt und den characters und das ist gar nicht schlecht
aber es hat immer irgendwelche perversen einlagen zwischendurch du denkst es ist eine ganz normale
fantasy story und auf einmal steht dann irgendwie irgendein anime girl im flur bei nacht mit
einem zauberhut rum und ich denke mir okay normale fantasy fantasy story auf einmal nimmt
die ihre hand und steckt die sich zwischen die beine ich bin ich denn hier gelandet das
ist aber eigentlich ist das story technische alles vollkommen ok aber zwischendurch hat
es aus welchen gründen auch immer übelste perverse einlagen keine ahnung warum ok was
wird mir stehen geblieben wir wollen hinter haben hier hinter font was die falls ihm noch
da alles klar komm ganz ganz wir kommen jetzt haben wir das überall jetzt haben wir diesen
von überall und jetzt sieht es auch gleich viel picker aus
nein nein also laut laut genre nicht laut genre ist das irgendwie fantasy sonst was
irgendwie nix nix hentai mäßiges gewesen dafür ist es auch nicht booba genug dafür
ist es eigentlich zu zurückhaltend aber ich verstehe nicht warum die quasi aus einer
ganz normalen fantasy story zwischendrin irgendwelche perversen einlagen brauchen kein schimmer
wahrscheinlich ganz ehrlich realistisch betrachtet ist es wahrscheinlich so das richtet sich
hauptsächlich an irgendwie ein junges männliches publikum und was macht man um die dazu zu
kriegen den graben zu gucken man baut halt neben an der fantasy story noch ein bisschen
booba zeug ein anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären wahrscheinlich wird es auch so sein
braucht er hier auch noch ein border man sieht man es nicht ok gut genug rum gebastelt
kann man uns um unseren craft qul zeug kümmern sieht doch eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus
oder sortieren wird noch pains champ das auf die reihe zu kriegen sage ich euch ok wir
müssen unser backend zeug bauen also als erstes würde ich sagen bevor wir craft qul zeug
machen machen wir mal einen ganz normalen get requests und holen uns irgendwelche alerts
machen wir mal machen wir das mal wieder weg auch nicht auch die klasse mit der farbe weg
so also ich muss was vom server abrunden was wie muss dann so wie sieht dann so ein gewöhnlicher
monitoring alert aus also was hat was haben wir denn da was was brauchen das ding das
ding braucht eine id das ding braucht einen name da steht dann so was drin wie festplatte
voll oder sowas das ding braucht irgendwo was was es ausgelöst hat also zum beispiel
irgendwie host server service was auch immer wo dann drin steht wo das herkommt dann braucht
es genau genau sowas braucht das auf jeden fall die schreibt man das sowas ja so und
dann würde ich sagen braucht es noch ein environment das dann da noch dabei ist es
live ist es testing ist es sonst was so in der richtung würde ich sagen passt das ach
ja und ein start und ein start datum timestamp braucht es noch genau start the time started
warum geht man shortcut nicht zum hochschieben der zeilen hallo warum man shortcut zum zeilen
hochschieben geht nicht ok so gut dort wir generieren jetzt einfach mal ein ray an alerts
zum testen ne wir machen das mit faker viel besser wir machen das mit faker mit bogus
heißt ja faker der wollte namen faker nicht faken so ok da liegen wir machen jetzt einfach
500 500 alerts 500 fake alerts also war new faker alerts so also random random daten generieren
also was brauchen wir denn wir brauchen eine id wir brauchen eine id so wie soll er die
random id generieren hallo kann das overlay mal nicht so nerven der soll die id generieren
mit gibt es gibt es ja überhaupt sowas id oder sowas hasheids random id gut eine gut
wollen wir haben genau unbedingt kein int gut hat der faker gs nicht alles gelöscht
nee aber was war denn noch mal das maintained doch jetzt der ursprüngliche faker gs typ
ist irgendwie verschwunden oder so und der neue faker gs typ hat jetzt irgendwie gelöscht
weil er nicht kostenlos für oh nein oh nein ok ich darfs heute noch verwenden leute ich
darfs heute noch verwenden ich darfs ich darfs noch verwenden ok nice luck gehabt skill
killer dankeschön für elf monate subscription du kochst hier nudel bolognese poggers ok
gut generieren rule 4 so environment ok environments ist relativ easy was machen wir was gibt es
denn für environments in unserem test monitoring system ich würde sagen es gibt live es gibt
tests und es gibt def oder so reicht so pick random environments so random environments
generieren für 500 alerts dann was müssen wir da noch füllen ein name oh da brauche
ich jetzt eine liste da brauche ich jetzt da muss ich mir selbst eine liste machen mit
mit sinnvollen alarmen name was gibt es denn da für sinnvolle messages gleich ok wir denken
uns jetzt mal ganz schnell einfach 20 verschiedene sinnlos monitoring meldung aus so ab ab ist
keine fehler meldung dauernd dauernd dauernd keine ahnung network disk usage memory usage
cpu cpu usage drive full ja das können wir über disk usage machen on fire keine schlechte
idee temperature chat wir brauchen mehr wir brauchen mehr monitoring mehr monitoring kategorien
ich bin sehr unkreativ was so was angeht pink time ja warum nicht pink pink time mail you
können wir noch machen das kenne ich weil das haben wir auf der arbeit das kommt bei uns auf der
arbeit manchmal vor disk speed nee disk speed ist blöd keine ahnung service dauernd oder so
das ist eine gute gute meldung glaube ich die sollte ab und zu mal drin auftauchen
ab und zu mal cpu laut haben wir schon cpu usage keine ahnung mir fällt mir fällt mir nicht ein
gerade das ist ein array könnte auch ein enum draus machen in dem fall ja keine ahnung es
reicht so name pick random messages ok rule so was braucht man jetzt noch name haben wir
schon severity hatten wir da hatten wir das schon nee levels nennen wir das mal so da gibt es
critical es gibt error es gibt warning und es gibt keine ahnung es gibt info oder so wir machen
einfach vier levels copy paste immer levels so und jetzt brauchen wir glaube ich nur noch
eins und zwar was habe ich noch vergessen sauce da nehmen wir einfach hostname da nehmen wir
einfach dann da generieren wir einfach random random hostname und gut ist sauce muss sie
irgendwie mal sinnvoll sinn haben dass wir den kram verwenden internet host domain domain name
ok gut so wir generate mal kurz rules generate 500 alerts und schießen das über die api zurück
schauen wir mal ob das funst run karl achso kann ich den kann ich hier den port angeben worauf der
runnen soll ah cool guck mal htp doppelpunkt doppelslash local house doppelpunkt port 5000
dann kommen die sie nicht in die quere mit den ports und es ist immer der gleiche port so 5000
so wenn jetzt alles klappt kriege ich hier 500 alerts zurück ob ich krieg 500 alerts zurück ja
guckt 500 random generated alerts kriegen wir jetzt zurück jeweils mit unterschiedlicher
id olaf punkt bis es daun leute fack nein nicht daun die mail queue auf olaf punkt bis ist zu hoch
scheiße was machen wir da jetzt randy mssql quer que ist der mss ql auf randy.com ist kaputt die
zeit ist immer gleich achso ja nee die zeit sollte ich vielleicht auch noch randomize da
hast schon recht da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht hallo punkt da hast da habe ich gar nicht
dran gedacht started at f time oh nee date date kriege ich hier irgendwie kriege ich ein ordentliches
datetime raus between ah get a random between start and end das ist eine gute idee recent
last few days das finde ich gut weil monitoring meldungen können ja nur in der vergangenheit
liegen es kann ja keine fehler melden die in die zukunft die in der zukunft auftreten werden
so ok dann starten wir das noch mal neu gucken jetzt noch mal wie es mit der zeit aussieht ja ja
zeit ok startet 25 12 vor 31 24 ok nice ok damit kommen damit können wir glaube ich arbeiten das
ist schon mal gut ok auf geht's dann machen wir fetsch und fetschen den kram hier also miss
leute ich muss trinken gleich mal wieder auffüllen ok wir fetschen mal eine runde fetsch das function
was ist denn heute los man am husten wie gesagt husten bitte die ganze woche also
function async function get alerts wir machen jetzt wir machen mal kein craft
wir machen ganz normales fetsch und füllen die tabelle damit und gucken wie wir das hin
bekommen weil das ist ein dass das erst mal funktioniert bevor man kraft als euch machen
ok also fetsch wait fetsch soll wir rufen sachen ab von htp doppelt punkt doppelt
gleich localhost port localhost port 5000 einfach nur so mehr gibt es nicht so machen
wir einfach jetzt hier let alerts da kommt das ergebnis rein alerts gleich await jason
so der sollte jetzt normalerweise in den fetsch request mal gucken wir mal ob er das macht macht
einen fetsch macht jede menge cash cash kann anbleiben macht einen fetsch websocket what the fuck
ich will keine dir den fetsch das da oder ne port 5000 müsste das sein wo ist der fetsch
jetzt blöd sehe ich sehe ich den plus nett ach ja nee wo ist mein fetsch ich ruf die
funktion all noch bin ich dumm lull ok geht nicht warum kors alter dieser crap man
war skate kann das ding das proxen
jetzt ist jetzt habe ich habe es kaputt gemacht
es ist einfach gecrashed
ne das funktioniert
ok das muss ich das fetsch muss ich auspacken 5000 5000
shutting down
ok kors das heißt ich muss jetzt erstmal kors enable ja wunderbar also wie ging das
denn jetzt noch mal app use kors allow allow any header allow any method allow any origin
reicht das schon fragezeichen das schon genug was jetzt kors service not registered ok keine
ahnung
der hätte aber warum der hätte
wie enable ich das denn jetzt hier kann es sein dass ich ihm sagen muss bilder services
kors ah so so ging das passt mal auf jetzt funst easy jetzt darf ich auch drauf zugreifen
zack mein fetsch hat funktioniert doch du hast recht vm warfalls hast recht so get alerts
schauen wir mal ob mein fetsch geklappt hat fetsch
hier kriege ich meine alerts ok so alerts sind am start das heißt ich kann den kram jetzt
hier ersetzen durch eine fleife so copy pasten wir das mal ok aus dem kopf swellen schleife
irgendwas mit klammern und each each each ach du scheiße kriege ich das aus dem kopf
hin wie ging das denn noch mal war das überhaupt each oder war das
und jetzt dann hier den kram rein ok nice guck mal ich meine es ist alles das gleiche
weil es noch hardcoded ist aber allein schon dass es so oft auftaucht sieht man dass das
prinzip prinzipiell geht schick schick schick so da müssen wir uns jetzt die einzelnen
sachen hier raus kreben dass das klappt also das erste ist hier so hier muss eine funktion
rein die auswertet welche farbe es bekommen soll
machen wir mal function function wenn wir das mal irgendwie severity to color
mal gucken wie wir das gleich gleich einbauen aber wir können erst mal was einbauen von
dem wir wissen dass es funktioniert so alert startet add haben wir schon ist die zeit von
jedem alert drinne nice aber halt unsortiert und alles sortieren müssen wir dann auch noch
so alert startet dann brauchen wir hier den text alert wie habe ich das genannt name
oder so name guck hier disk usage pingtime kegw und dann brauchen wir alert source haben
wir das glaube ich genannt ja jetzt haben wir unseren krempel schon drin
jetzt ist auch echt ganz brauchbar aus so jetzt wollen sie nur überlegen wie wir die
farben wie wir das mit den mit den farben hinkriegen dass es dass dass die dass die
farben stimmen cute.chat nur 5000 euro also wir gucken jetzt mal hier rein welche farbe
brauchen wir hier wir brauchen
das ist view syntax ich glaube glaube ins welt ging es einfach so severity to color und zwar
ich hoffe ich tippe hier keinen mist ich verschreibe mich nicht so ich muss mal noch was trinken
und noch einen bombe rein schieben
wäre glaube ich cool wenn die nafbar mit runter gehen würde ob 5 hat idee sticky nafbar wobei
die nafbar sollte nicht mit runter gehen leute die teil der tabellen header sollte mit runter
gehen oder die nafbar ist doch egal der tabellen header sollte mit runter gehen messer pfeil
hat fix oder irgendwie so ne glaube ich war mal sticky es gibt sticky fix static und absolut
ich glaube sticky brauchen wir in dem fall gucken wir mal sticky ich glaube ich muss
die table relativ machen dazu das ist funst nope no pass ach ich muss noch definieren
ok top top null oh poggers guck mal da es ist sticky so da braucht background gray 800
ist das ding standardmäßig zack guck mal wir haben sticky tablehead das war cool easy
ist aber einfach gewesen jetzt wir sollten dann noch irgendeinen strich unten drunter
machen glaube ich dass man das unterteilen kann wenn man border bottom to machen ja oder
einfach nur so einfach nur so und dann sagen wir border gray hey gar nicht übel find ich
gut was hatten wir bei der schrift auch noch mal gray 800 gray 400 ist die schrift auch
gray 400 ich finde 700 tatsächlich sogar besser das ist gar nicht das ist ok das kann
ich lasse ich mir so gefallen als wenn ich jetzt oh nee was ist das hä warum floatet
das nicht mit warum warum floatet mein mein border mein bottom border nicht mit anzeige
es raus was ist das hier warum warum muss ich vielleicht das da rein packen border row
alle sticky ist aber das gehört doch zu dem element dazu ok da bin ich jetzt da bin ich
jetzt überfragt ok der geht nicht ja dann weiß ich grad auch nicht wie man das gescheit
macht dann muss das jetzt so bleiben wir müssen uns erstmal um die hintergrundfarbe kümmern
also if if gleich gleich critical dann returnen wir was haben wir gesagt was hatten wir noch
mal für eine farbe rosé oder versuch mal mit einem shadow exzellente feifei idee also
so was hier shadow der geht auch nicht mit man sieht den kaum aber der geht auch nicht
mit stimmt ja du hast recht ja ja wir machen das mir also hier fuchs ja fuchs ja 600 es
ist so weil border zu dem boxmode gehört du kannst es mit border collapse rausnehmen
denke ich iq probier mal aus probier mal aus also kann ich jetzt hier sagen border bottom
aber dass man auch ordentlich sieht vier so es kalt nicht jetzt was collapse keine ahnung
bin ich bin ich bin ich zu lau iq für oder was hin zu bekommen ich meine ich könnte
einfach in den diff drinnen machen oder ich könnte in den diff drinnen machen und das
unten drunter doch dort hat es hat das drin hat aber nicht funktioniert
packs an den table header nicht an die tr du meinst du meinst border collapse und dann
border bottom vier ja das wird mir auch noch einfallen dass ich einen zweiten header mach
und den unten drunter pack oder sowas ja alter warum ist css denn so pains champion immer
lg habe ich das hier eigentlich habe ich das hier bolt gemacht oder warum ist das so fett
ok es ist lg deswegen ist das so fett wo habe ich es denn hier fett gemacht warum ist die
überschrift zu dick sehe ich das jetzt bloß nicht oder ist das standard styling für den
table header dass die überschrift dick ist das macht wahrscheinlich das macht wahrscheinlich
das standard element schon so dass es die schrift dicker macht ok wir brauchen jetzt
erst mal uns also critical critical ok critical hatten wir keine ahnung fangen wir mit warning
hatten wir uns noch nichts ausgedacht ok critical ist was hatten wir da bg fuchs jahr 600 so
als errohr errohr red 600 die rosé rosé das ist der go style von klammern und ifs den
mag ich nicht so warning warning mache ich jetzt einfach orange orange guck mal hier
es nimmt form an sondern das letzte das letzte ist ja quasi dann info oder sowas und info
ist ganz einfach return return blue indigo ja leute ich muss sagen dass sie es eigentlich
gar nicht mal so so hässlich vor allem man kann es gut lesen weil er das in den switch
ja macht jetzt eigentlich jetzt wirklichen unterschied oder das ist dumm so ist ich mag
das so viel mehr so so ist besser besser bester klammern style leute was sagt ihr so klammern
so klammern oder so klammern also das versus so ja so ist das längere oder das kürzere
so kürzer echt ich hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht ich finde das längere besser abstimmung
ok klammern style abstimmung alles klar leute wenige zeilen mehr zeilen ihr müsst ja mal
dran denken weniger zeilen nicht automatisch besser lesbar ich meine das ist zwar kompakter
aber ich finde da jetzt zu erkennen wo was anfängt ist auch nicht so easy ok also ich
würde sagen zwei drittel sind für weniger zeilen für diesen goleng style und die anderen
sind so für den klassischen style wobei es auch kein das parzell parzell gibt es die
gleiche diskussion immer ok weniger zeilen hat gewonnen also die
meisten leute bevorzugen das und ein drittel bevorzugt das ich gehöre dazu aber ok standardmäßig
macht es das so beim auto formatieren dann lassen wir es so gut wir sollten noch ein
bisschen abstand zwischen diesen zeilen hier machen leute das ist nicht richtig allein
doch ist es wir sollten noch ein bisschen abstand zwischen den einzelnen zeilen machen
bei wollen wir das das wir weil so weil so hängt so hängt das ein bisschen ein bisschen
nahe aneinander dran können wir nicht hier einfach sagen wie kriege ich denn da jetzt
was gescheites rein zusätzlich zu den styles und die farbe würde als kart in einer separaten
spalte besser aussehen nee ich finde so ist das besser normalerweise hast du es ja nicht
so bundig ja normalerweise hast du da eigentlich nur dann was ich die zwei die zwei dinge hauptsächlich
drauf und auch zur gleichen zeit dann ich finde es insofern besser weil man muss davon
ausgehen dass man das auf einer monitor wand hat sich von weitem anguckt und dann ist es
deutlich besser zu erkennen ob es jetzt was schlimmes ist oder nicht wenn wenn der hintergrund
die passende farbe hat wie kriege ich denn jetzt zusätzlich jetzt noch was dabei so
das ist ja hässlich wie die nacht plus gleich
die zwei oder so das ist schon mal besser oder
woher weiß man was die farbe heißt auswendig lernen gibt ja nur vier verschiedene farben
du kannst die funktion auch in den klassen string schreiben und die anderen dahinter
was was also in view könnte ich einmal so machen und und und einmal so aber das geht
ja hier nicht das geht nee oder muss da muss ich interpolate string machen dass das funktioniert
so wird das so wird das nicht funktionieren oder
nee guck mal ja ach nee so wie das funst woher weiß er denn dass er das hier interpolaten
muss
oder es ist egal ob die geschweiften klammern in dem string stehen oder nicht der ersetzt
das immer ein oder was ja ok das ist in ordnung
sollte die haus nahmen triggern mich ich brauche ich brauche ich brauche bessere haus nahmen
wir müssen mal wir müssen mal kurz wir müssen mal kurz kreativ sein war host names gleich
ok hausnamen db web server app back end back back end niemals klasse also man soll das
nicht in interpolate sachen stecken ok gateway sehr gute idee proxy lb cash windows was
auch mail ingress storage ai block chain oh racism hier block chain so backup sehr gut
alter ich kann nicht schreiben back up ok das reicht switch router
das sind netzwerk equipment raus und außerdem war das die cisco schreibweise printer ja
das wird lustig in kombination msql fehler auf dem drucker
das ist ok das reicht so so dann machen sie mich nicht domain pick random aus host names
host names so und jetzt sieht es wahrscheinlich gleich auch besser aus von den von den sources
wo das herkommt ja app ai srv lb cache gw das sieht schon deutlich serveriger aus und
da hinten dran können wir jetzt noch da war das gleiche was wir eben schon hatten da sagen
wir jetzt punkt internet domain name und jetzt ist das glaube ich ganz nice proxy anissa
punkt org ingress alisha punkt name christianer punkt name alles da soll finde ich das gut
das hat das hat das hat tatsächlich was von server namen cash ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
zum testen ist es aber ok das können wir so lassen ok schick das sieht ok aus und das
oh Gott wie mache ich denn jetzt das suchen in dieser tabelle man mich krauts davor das
zu programmieren aber jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal die craft erst die craft ql geschichte
an also wir kriegen jetzt unsere werte von noch mit einem ganz normalen fetch so und
jetzt gucken wir uns die sache mit craft ql an und jetzt hört es auf wo ich ahnung habe
swelt das werden wir als craft ql verwenden weil warum weil ich dazu letztens eine serie
auf youtube gesehen habe und ich glaube es gibt nicht so viele craft ql clients fürs welt
es gibt irgendeine apollo ab wandlung und den hier ok npm install was macht denn safe
versus normal was g query not jquery aber eine was für ein ding not like a craft ql
fetscher und cash for swell kit kinder subscriptions ok craft ql code gen plug in was warum ich
will keine code code generen craft ql files was will das von mir ach das ist für type
script type script kann das subscriptions not available yet ok dann können wir das nicht
verwenden richtig advanced hier ja heute schon gut craft ql installieren so jetzt haben wir
das einmal installiert und jetzt muss ich auf surfer auf surfer seite ja noch craft ql
hinzufügen da nehmen wir das package hot chocolate chocolate das ist ein craft ql surfer für
dot net version preview ich hätte geni stable subscriptions will ich haben gleich subscriptions
und die asp dot net variante so damit habe ich schon ein paar mal was gemacht ich hoffe
ich kriege das meiste hier noch so der spur nach zusammen wie das funktioniert dange für
den zapp ok craft ql also wir müssen ihm sagen das coole an an diesem craft ql surfer ist
hier den nicht den den den ich eben hinzugefügt habe die haben so eine spielwiese dabei aber
ich sollte line rap noch ausschalten oder adolf ist daun leute service daun ab adolf
dot net ein etwas unglücklicher name jetzt für eine domain aber ok es ist random ist
es normal dass man in sie schab war statt den typ nimmt erscheint mir ein wenig vergeudet
wenn man schon die möglichheit den typ direkt zu der fin war definiert den typ direkt guck
mal wenn du hier sagst messages der erkennt dass du es den string array ist das ist einfach
nur zum abkürzen dass du nicht doppelt dass du es nicht doppelt schreiben musst also das
ist das hier ist exakt das gleiche wie das hier das macht keinen unterschied es ist nur
dass du es nicht schreiben musst so und es gibt übrigens die entgegengesetzte variante
es gibt auch die entgegengesetzte variante hier ist es so die rechte seite ist klar was
es für einen typ ist dementsprechend kannst du die linke seite dynamisch machen du kannst
aber auch sagen string blubb gleich nu das funktioniert auch also mit ja string hat kein
leeren constructor aber prinzipiell funktioniert das du kannst wenn du es links definiert hast
auch recht dass ich kann alert zum beispiel guck wenn ich links definiert hat muss ich
rechts nicht definieren wobei das in dieser kombination relativ selten verwendet wird
also du musst es nur auf einer seite definieren wenn die rechte seite klar ist kannst du die
linke seite automatisch einfügen lassen und wenn die linke seite klar definiert ist kannst
du die rechte seite automatisch einfügen lassen wobei man das an der stelle nicht so oft verwendet
sondern eher an anderen stellen zum beispiel wenn ich nur funktionen habe oder so was wo
die parameter schon klar sind aber das ist das gleiche also es war macht ist nicht wirklich
dynamisch dynamisch wäre dynamic dynamic wäre dynamisch und das siehst du auch da wenn
ich da jetzt versucht darauf zuzugreifen du hast überhaupt kein auto complete mehr und
sonst was dafür könnte ich so was machen wie message messages blubb und es würde keine
fehler meldung beim kompilieren geben erst zur laufzeit das braucht man aber normalerweise
nicht aber es gibt eine sache da ist dynamic echt praktisch das ist für jason pasen oder
generell für für sachen die man über irgendeine api kriegt oder so da kann dynamic manchmal
wirklich praktisch sein aber ansonsten braucht man so gut wie nicht so craft ql wo sind aber
starke ab use craft ql nein ok ich muss in das tutorial gucken minimal api haben die
da für ein beispiel introduction getting started haben wir gemacht brauchen wir nicht
hier bild services aha ich muss das anpassen das geht jetzt doch nicht so einfach mehr
mit minimal mit mit minimal star minimal api wobei nie hätte das haben wir doch schon
so bilder wie geht das jetzt bilder services services at craft ql ok craft ql server muss
ich machen craft ql server und dann muss ich eben sagen was für typen ich dafür verwenden
will at query type genau at query type den muss ich jetzt gleich noch anlegen ok public
class query haben wir doch bestimmt ein beispiel für bist denn serious max haben wir da ein
beispiel für ach so ok einfach einfach ganz normal lehrklasse property muss es eine funktion
sein ne alert ach hier query type das muss eine funktion sein ja ok cannot get alerts
das ist ja nur zum testen ob sie die ganze craft ql geschichte überhaupt funktioniert
geben wir mal in leeren in leeren alert zurück oh jetzt habe ich irgendeinen mist getippt
von ks alter zack ist mir zu viel jetzt so return new der mich verarschen habe ich irgendwann
ich habe die klammern vergessen ich habe die klammern vergessen da weiß gar nicht was
ich machen will wohl jetzt ok mit new genau ich will den leeren ich will den leeren alert
zurückgeben das ist falsch oh was habe ich denn jetzt hier gemacht hier ist was guck
mal nach das gehört da nicht hin array empty alert alter hey fat time das kenne ich noch
gar nicht ne moment ich will kein empty alert ich will ja mit einem einem alert drinne
muss public sein ok so als haben wir ein alert am start der kriegt irgendwie eine id new
good oder ne gut gut gut new brauche ich zum testen ob es funktioniert gut mehr braucht
das nicht können die autocomplete gibt schon auf an der stelle denkt sich kein bock mehr
ok so query type ad query type ok wie geht es wie geht es weiter ad query type und dann
muss ich sagen bilder bild map craft ql ok also hier ab map craft ql doch wenn ich es
als richtig gemacht habe soll ich in query absetzen können schauen wir mal warum kein
typescript weil weil ich mich da um noch mehr neues zeug kümmern muss so localhost slash
craft ql bäm das admin interface für unser craft ql ist da was heißt das admin interface
das ausprobier interface das würde ich übrigens wenn ich nicht in entwicklung bin abschalten
das möchte man nicht bei einem live service haben wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte wenn
man das in release kompiliert schalte das automatisch schon ab programmierst du noch
ja in letzter zeit habe ich mich in so weit durchgemogelt dass ich wieder ein bisschen
mehr zeug selbst programmieren kann aber ich mache immer noch hauptsächlich guck ich
würde das zeug an was andere programmieren ist halt naja so ist halt so wie es ich gehe
mal kurz was zu trinken holen
so wieder da
dieses interface hat zum beispiel facebook offen und immer an bestimmt nicht also dieses
da bestimmt nicht die verwenden ja was ganz anderes intern für craft ql ja das ist was
anderes was du da verlinkt hast das ist nicht das ist nicht der nicht das ausprobier interface
das was anderes das ist so so so so craft ql explorer tools gibt es jede menge ok wir
machen mal wir müssen mal unser unser craft ql query ausprobieren also query das ist ja
auch feifett leute feifett farbgebung oder guckt euch das mal an erkennt ihr alles erkennt
ihr dass der query steht alerts und die id zack bam funst also craft ql ist an sich funktional
dann bauen wir das doch mal warum ist jetzt warum ist jetzt broken ach so weil ich noch
gar nicht wieder gestartet habe npm install open so dann bauen wir das doch mal ein bei
uns dann bauen wir das doch jetzt mal bei uns ein wie können wir den get request machen
mit swelt und craft ql zeige ich mal her swelt bindings haben wir warum wir nicht setup client
import create client das klingt doch schon mal gut weiter im text create client get top
wir haben keine authentifizierung also authentifizierung ist echt für noobs unser service ist sicher
da braucht keine authentifizierung was ist craft ql eine alternative zum abfragen von
daten zu zu klassischen rests requests oder soap was man früher verwendet hat kennt noch
jemand soap requests xml xml soap kennt das noch jemand also wenn ich soap sehe also wenn
ich diesen diesen müll hier sehe da fällt mir plus dazu ein lange nicht mal verwendet
das emote hier was anderes fällt mir das ist wirklich das schlimmste was es gibt guckt
ich finde auch wpf xml nicht nice das ist eines der sachen die ich da dran nicht nicht
nice finde so next du musstest was auf der arbeit machen mit ja mein beilite so create
client was haben wir denn hier noch in it client ok das das moment das ist die kurz
variante davon in it client alles klar in it client sind wir hier den geblieben ja gut
diese get alerts kann man aus kommentieren das war jetzt ja nicht mehr so war craft ql
import in it clients port 5000 craft ql ok noch gibt es keine fehler und wie macht man
its queries query hier so queries queries operation store jetzt wird es aber richtig
advanced hier was wollen die dann von mir wobei das sollte ich vielleicht nach dem client
machen bad requests warum läuft doch ach so ja weil das weil das nicht stimmt wir wollen
query machen alerts und davon die id so ok scheint zu funktionieren scheint zu funktionieren
gibt zumindest keine fehler meldung bei dem query gucken wir uns mal an ich lasse es jetzt
hier einfach mal auf die seite rendern du du jetzt ja gut es heißt ja nicht du du soll
ja es soll ja eigentlich soll das alerts heißen nennen wir es auch gleich mal so es
ist already been declared ach da oben lull weg
wirklich funktionieren tut das jetzt nicht oder jason stringify patching true ganz
gut ach hier alles klar ok funst aber text text dass ihr sehen könnt text white er ruft
er ruft den kram ab alerts halten jetzt so mein test alert so also wir wollen ja aber
kein query machen wir wollen es subscription machen dass der immer sich automatisch die
neuesten alerts holt also wie geht das denn jetzt wie mache ich subscriptions hier in dieser
minimal api dann brauchen wir sowas wie add subscription type da kann ich mich doch dran
erinnern saab schon habe ich das jetzt richtig geschrieben es gibt es gibt wörter siehst
du nein es gibt wörter da verschreibe ich mich prinzipiell immer subscription ist auch
so ein ding so subscription create type subscription wunderbar so da muss jetzt aber in den in
den guide gucken weil ich keinen passen schimmer habe wie man glaub advanced topics oder sowas
subscriptions wie das funktioniert subscriptions nee so habe ich das nicht gemacht ich weiß
es gab was wo man das alles in eine machen konnte web sockets braucht man ok web sockets
klar für subscriptions brauchen web sockets sonst kann er der server nicht bescheid sagen
wenn es was neues gibt das leuchtet ein also brauchen wir app use web sockets in memory
brauchen wir nicht reddit provider brauchen wir nicht publishing events brauchen wir
in dem fall auch nicht wo ist das minimal beispiel die haben doch so ein minimal beispiel hier
immer gehabt das da das da das brauche ich zum glück habe ich damit schon was gemacht
sonst wäre ich jetzt hoffnungslos aufgeschmissen wahrscheinlich auf server sein so also klasse
subscription so diesen ganzen müll hier brauchen wir nicht nennen wir irgendwie get alerts
wir kriegen ein enum zurück wir kriegen ein enum zurück von alerts arrays achso nee eigentlich
von eins an alerts das ist ich hab zehn wegen top level programs ja ist es das dotnet sechs
oder sicher nee sicher zehn ist es noch ne ja ja genau so das war mein esseng und wir
sind jetzt mal ganz wir machen jetzt die brute force variante true lulvee a wait task delay
wir schicken einfach jede sekunde ein eine neue antwort raus jild return und gucken ob
es funktioniert mir geht es einfach nur darum rauszufinden ob der ob der krempel funktioniert
und dann versuche ich das mal zu erklären wachs wann wirst du zum vtuber ja ich wollte
ja mal so was in auftrag geben aber so ein avatar habe ich aber nicht habe ich noch nicht
gemacht so so wenn ich glück habe funktionieren meine subscriptions jetzt zumindest erst mal
mit mit mit diesem statischen ding so kreff ql schema aktualisieren subscription nice
so also subscription alerts uns guck mal ich krieg jede sekunde neue alerts also meine
jeden sekunde ist klar weil jede sekunde schicke ich einfach den gleichen leeren alert
wieder so das ist jetzt ein bisschen frei fett was hier passiert und zwar der client baut
eine websocket verbindung auf zum server und der server antwortet ihm immer jede sekunde
mit einem array aus leeren alerts weil ich dazu reingeschrieben habe dass das funktioniert
ist folgendermaßen du musst ihm einmal sagen dass du ein innumerable zurück gibst weil
das ist ja ein stream aus antworten zu so einer subscription also die hört ja nicht auf du
subscribes zu einem stream aus events deswegen muss das ohne sequenz sein so und damit das
funktioniert musste ich ihm sagen dass du nicht returnen willst return wäre ja komplett
aus der funktion rausgehen sondern du musst yield return sagen yield return ist im prinzip
der bleibt hier drinnen gibt ein wert zurück macht dann hier weiter und gibt den nächsten
wert zurück also sprich der unterbricht das hier quasi kurz so und jetzt müssen wir den
richtigen krempel zurückgeben aber vielleicht nicht einmal die sekunde einmal diese sekunde
ist ein bisschen krass ich glaube ich muss bald aufhören zu streamen weil weil husen
und hals es hielt ungefähr so wie channels in goleng ne channels ist ja eine multithreaded
geschichte mit du startest was das hier ist nicht multithreaded na wobei in dem fall in
dem fall könnte es durchaus im tag über den taskpool trotzdem multithreaded sein aufhören
wie lang nein für heute da müssen wir was sagt er was offiziell ist ich habe yield return
was sagen die dazu kontextabhängiges schlüsselwort alles klar wir lesen das natürlich auf deutsch
logisch haben wir da irgendwas gescheites dafür damit ich das ordentlich erklären kann
ich mache mal kurz eine neue konsolenanwendung console app 6 wunderbar new window also zum
beispiel stell dir mal vor willst du allen ring stream nö aber ich werde spielen ich
werde es auf jeden fall spielen so jetzt stelle ich mal vor du hast irgendwie einen programm
was irgendwelche messwerte zurück gibt ja zum beispiel du hast jetzt irgendwas was
ein temperatursensor so aber ganz ganz ganz billig sein du hast ein temperatursensor oder
temperatursensor der mist der mist ja jedes mal wenn du ihn fragst das heißt es ist quasi
ein unendlich langer stream an neuen messwerten und jetzt hat die frage wie bildet man das
am besten ab so zum beispiel es gibt jetzt bei uns ich habe klasse klasse temp sensor
nummer zum zum erklären und dann hast du jetzt hier sowas wie was weiß ich riet die klassische
variante du sagst jetzt du willst du machst quasi in riet und gibt es dann jedes mal
ein messwert zurück was habe ich was habe ich falsch gemacht so du gibst dann jedes
mal ein messwert weg messwert zurück das heißt du musst jetzt in deinem programm hier oben
dann eine schleife machen und und was zum ist das wo ist der kram kaputt also du willst
dann hier oben sowas hier machen new temp sensor habe ich irgendwas verkehrt gemacht
oder ist man weiter gerade am rumspacken sondern sagst du irgendwie weil schuhe und dann wird
sie drinne keine an konz konzol konzol lock sind aber habe ich warum spacken das so rum
als public und dann kannst du endlich lang den krempel hier ausgeben wenn du damit jetzt
aber nicht sequenziell was machen willst oder wenn du das beispielsweise übers netzwerk
übertragen willst oder wenn das ding was ich wie erkläre ich das denn jetzt am besten
ich habe keine ahnung ich zeige das jetzt einfach mal also du kannst aber anstatt das
so zu machen dass du quasi jedes mal hier drinnen ab abfragen du kannst auch das ding
sagen hey das ist ein stream quasi unendlich langer ein unendlich langer stream aus neuen
werten sondern du kannst du sagen so ein normal und kommt da jetzt zurück und anstatt dass
du jedes mal ein wert zurück gibst kannst du jetzt auch sagen hier drinnen die schleife
machen und den messen lassen aber warum spackt man weiter mit autocomplete kratz so krass
rum verstehe nicht so und jetzt sagst du dass ich jetzt also irgendwas ist hier kaputt habe
ich irgendwo falschen falsche einrückung oder sowas irgendwas ist mega prokkenkarte
dann würdest du nämlich sagen hielt return den eigentlichen messwert und dann hast du
den vorteil dann musst du dich nicht in deinem main programm drum kümmern dann würdest
du nämlich einfach sagen vor each ich habe doch irgendwas vergessen irgendwas stimmt
doch hier nicht dass sein das mit dem autocomplete so rumspackt vor each da kannst du nämlich
sagen keine an value in sensor reads vielleicht spackt weiter auch wegen top level rum oder
so keine ahnung kann sein ne ne das sollte das sollte das sollte eigentlich ok sein so
und jetzt kannst du hier quasi diese schleife und endlich lang laufen lassen so lange bis
dein sensor keine werte mehr liefert was ja vielleicht keine ahnung irgendwann mal vorkommt
oder so jetzt musst du dich aber nicht hier oben drum kümmern sondern hast das logisch
viel besser an der stelle man merkt eben nicht ob die ein oder falsche wenn die klammern
sind ne mit einrückung hat das ja auch nichts zu tun so ich kann es gerade nicht sinnvoller
erklärt zumindest ist das für streams an daten ganz nützlich die sache ist jetzt die
wir wollen ja hier jetzt im prinzip diesen ganzen schmodder den wir hier oben machen
mit den werten generieren wollen wir eigentlich in der subscription klasse machen so map kommt
weg eigentlich wollen wir das hier drinne machen private alert generate so return rules
generate 500 und jetzt kriege ich alle sekunde jetzt kriege ich jede sekunde neue 500 alerts
gepusht das hat zwar mit der realität nichts zu tun ist aber zum ausprobieren ganz praktisch
also guckt wenn ich jetzt das ding ausführe und gehe hier auf meine craftql übersichtseite
und dann funktioniert das irgendwann so und wenn ich jetzt hier alerts subscriben dann
kriege ich pro sekunde kriege ich 500 neue alerts kann jetzt auch noch sagen ich will
jetzt dazu noch haben keine ahnung start and add und ich will den name noch dabei haben
ich also kriege jede sekunde 500 neue das ist natürlich bescheuert hat mit der realität
nichts zu tun muss man auch mal klar dazu sagen aber es funktioniert und das coole daran
ist ich muss jetzt auf dem client nicht permanent checken ob es was neues gibt sobald es server
seitlich was neues gibt kriege ich das gepusht auf den client also es ist umgedreht aktuell
müsste ich also mit fetch müsste ich keine ahnung alle 15 sekunden beim server neu anfragen
gibt es neue alerts gibt es neue alerts gibt es neue alerts und mit subscription sagt mir
der server bescheid sobald es neue alerts gibt dass sie jetzt hier im sekundentag kommen
ist ja rein zu testzwecken normalerweise kämen die halt unregelmäßig wenn es halt was gibt
genau so das müsste das müsste eigentlich jetzt so funktionieren vielleicht machen
wir das mal alle fünf sekunden und nicht unbedingt alle alle sekunde so und jetzt können
wir das mit unserem frontend temple ausprobieren wie macht man subscriptions wie macht man subscriptions
hier mit zwelt das ist das eigentliche das habe ich noch nie gemacht habe ich auch mit
mit diesem mit dieser library noch nie gemacht ich habe keinen lassen schimmer wie das funktioniert
überlegen nach was nach was suche ich schon da jetzt am besten du meinst mit stores mit
stores wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist das internen store hier ja naja es gibt zwei sachen
die stores ist die swelt geschichte subscriptions ist eine craftql geschichte also diese websocket
geschichte ist was von craftql das welt das irgendwie mit stores handelt ja meinetwegen
ne ne ne ne ne das das store subscribes meine ich nicht ich muss gucken wie ich den dem
beibringen dass der die websocket verbindung aufmacht und sich benachrichtigen lässt vom
server das steht hier aber auf der seite das habe ich schon gesehen das gibt sie irgendwie
unter advanced topics gibt es subscriptions und da kriegen wir das jetzt erklärt wie das
funktioniert aber ich habe da vorhin reingeschaut und echt nichts verstanden das müssen wir
erst mal uns in ruhe zu gemüte führen wie das wie das funktioniert so also to add support
for subscriptions we need to add subscription exchange to our client ah yes subscription
exchange jetzt ist alles klar leute oder natürlich feifert setting up craftql ganz selbstverständlich
ja sind wir uns einig ok also for for backends supporting craftql ws sie sie recommenden
den craftql ws client und dann gibt es noch setting up subscriptions transport for backends
supporting subscriptions transport und woher weiß ich jetzt was mein backends supportet
und was weiß ich im moment
ok support wollen die adden dafür haben die support geedit die haben noch keinen support
geedit dafür nein das geht nicht ins 12.6 weil 12.6 haben wir ja ist es jetzt schon
drinne oder nicht closed ok nein ich glaube nicht dass das drinne ist nein ok also wir
haben anscheinend kein craftql ws support sondern wir haben wenn wir glück haben nur
subscriptions transport ws ich habe keine ahnung was sie mir damit sagen wollen aber ich probiere
das jetzt einfach aus ja also client default exchanges subscribt what the fuck ich copy
paste sie mir das jetzt einfach und guck mir das an ok das bleibt da das kommt weg das
brauchen wir vielleicht noch init client noch wahrscheinlich nicht oder wahrscheinlich
was bin ich da sehen überhaupt was ist das ich hau ich hau den ganzen schmodder jetzt
mal weg hier so weg weg also failed operation store meine güde jetzt wird's ok es ist nicht
es ist falsches falsches package schon mal ok client default subscriber actually subscriber
client alles klar so und wir wollen nicht auf local auswählen auf local cost port 5000
moment client von ks dann in it klein brauche in it in it klein hatten wir doch eben oder
in it klein brauche zack ne ah exchange exchange easy ne internal server error warum weil failed
ah das ist das was was ich npm installen muss oder was subscription transports bs npm
install ok alles klar ok das ist doch schon mal besser alerts is not defined ja ich weiß
dass er jetzt nicht die feind ist aber ja dann dann machen wir das doch mal let alerts oder
alerts array is not a store with a subscribe method das heißt wie mache ich jetzt hier
den this query failed messages das der operation store eine fresse alter lull lull wie operation
store subscription alerts subscription alerts wir holen mal nur die id setzt ja erst mal
zum testen irrelevant was man da noch alles haben internal server error auf port 3000
wir wollen auch nicht port 3000 sondern port 5000 haben was ich da baue mach mal ausrufen
zeichen heute ich hab irgendeiner der 5 hat mods hat was geschrieben internal server warum
habe ich kein websocket wie warum soll ich kein websocket haben ja das 3000 ist richtig
da wird die webseite über ausgeliefert aber der fql server läuft auf 5000 ich weiß woran
das liegt browser ist welt if browser man muss checken ob man den browser ist man muss
checken ob man im browser ist if browser steinarna 5 danke für den sub check if browser der
versucht es ja serverseitig zu rendern standardmäßig was ja bescheuert ist import browser genau
man kann checken ob man den browser ist das brauchen wir klein brauchen wir nicht so also
if browser weil serverseitig funktioniert das nicht ok das leuchtet mir ein gut hey der
macht was guck mal da postchamp wie kriege ich jetzt die alerts da rein ich muss ich
muss noch mal in die doko gucken subscriptions hier subscription message handle subscription
also sage ich ihm jetzt wenn ich im browser bin subscription nicht messages alerts handle
subscript das ist doch das ist doch bloß jetzt braucht doch kein mensch hier das machen
lasst den kram hier mal raus gemacht doch jetzt macht doch keine extra funktion jetzt kommt
der inline rein oder auch nicht ok prinzipiell scheint ja schon mal zu funktionieren subscription
ist not defined weil aha operation store subscription muss ich importieren ok wait a minute funktioniert
das jetzt zack log data alerts array 500 komm mal da postchamp und ich kriege alle 5 sekunden
neue werte vom server geschickt easy einfach wildes copy pasten easy wildes copy pasten führt
zum erfolg so muss es sein was was genau passiert hier eigentlich gerade das ist ja auch nicht
ist nicht signal signal art das ist ja auch kräftige subscriptions alerts messages was
was soll denn messages überhaupt sein data ich will einfach nur haben return return
data fertig zack da ist es doch guck mal alerts data muss ich jetzt vielleicht noch punkt
alerts machen doch mal data so easy ja jetzt haben wir den ganzen kram hier drin so alles
klar wir fragen jetzt ab die id wir fragen den name ab wir brauchen diese verity fragen
ab und wir fragen das environment ab und wir fragen started ad ab oder das reicht erst
mal was haben wir sonst noch was man abfragen können bei alerts ok das war es ich hab ich
frag schon alles ab so wir sollen jetzt aber eigentlich sehen dass sich das alle 5 sekunden
ändert es ändert sich alle 5 sekunden seht ihr guck mal hier 1 2 3 4 5 zack ok ich kriege
5 alle 5 sekunden neue werte geschickt passt direkt production push klar wie immer wir
sind ja agil wir testen nichts mehr wir sind so agile wir haben das alles automatisiert
hyper agile wir skalieren schon diagonal unrecoverable error in index each only achso
wie sage ich ihm denn jetzt dass er das nur machen soll sekunde da gab es doch gab es
doch hier ein beispiel zu query hier alerts entries nee nee ich muss checken ob der nicht
mehr loading ist oder irgendwie sind ich muss mal kurz den kram hier noch mal einblenden
etching true achso einer fetching true ist immer da ist immer true fetching etching ist
immer true weil weil es ist ja eine subscription also muss ich quasi sowas was data ach nee
alerts data ist undefined oder eben if da vormachen oder sowas ach dollar das ist jetzt
ja ein store dollar alerts data
also muss ich ihm jetzt quasi sagen ach gucke mal das ist ja feifett ich könnte ich könnte
quasi einen spinner einblenden wobei nee ich will ja keinen spinner einblenden das ist
ja eine subscription die hört ja nie auf aber mit dem loading mit dem fetching das funktioniert
überhaupt nicht ich muss wirklich dann if da vormachen ich muss wirklich mal if to do
status so muss ein if da vormachen aber was was ist da noch mal drin informiert jason
ringify alerts falls wie so data nee direkt in data ist das drinne data so also ich muss
vor allem if machen ob in data was drinne ist anders anders funktioniert das nicht also
if if if alerts data so hey nee oder hey es funzt guck mal es funktioniert max du kannst
vor dem each ein add debug machen das ist cool guck mal es funktioniert alle fünf sekunden
kriegen wir neue neue monitoring komplett neue monitoring alerts da hat somit wie gesagt
haben wir der realität nichts zu tun aber es funktioniert nach welchen kriterien werden
die eingefärbt das purple ist critical rot ist error warning ist orange und info ist
blau das funktioniert guck mal ich kann euch sogar wir machen jetzt mal was anderes ich
beende das mal und dann gucken wir mal ja da muss jetzt wegen den web socket erst braucht
eine weile zum shutdown wir machen das jetzt mal ein bisschen schneller guck mal machen
das war ein bisschen schneller 500 millisekunden einfach nur mal gucken ob er sich reconnectet
der reconnectet sich guckt mal jetzt kriege ich alle 500 millisekunden komplett neuen
satz warum ist der haut warum ist der hostname undefined warum frage ich den vielleicht
nicht ab in meinem craftql frage ich den vielleicht nicht ab ja sauce haha guck mal da an es funktioniert
gut ich lasse ihn jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen weniger wild rumspringen so also das funktioniert
schon mal also wir kriegen jetzt vom server geschickt immer wenn es neue monitoring meldungen
gibt fake wohlgemerkt wir reden immer von fake monitoring meldungen weil das random
generated ist im hintergrund gut ai stefan punkt com ist daun anzeige ist raus so jetzt
müssen wir das noch sortieren weil so ist ja total hängen geblieben guck mal das ist
einfach random sortiert stefan ist daun ja paschale ist auch da meine pizzeria hier im
ort hieß so früher
blockchain molly.net
leak omg davon gibt es auch so wenige und selbst wenn man weiß ja schon sogar dass ich
in hannau wurde übrigens hannau leute noch mehr leak in hannau pass mal auf hannau hauptbahnhof
axt sck einsatz in hannau man steigt mit axt in linienbus und schreit fahrgäste an das
war gestern vorgestern vorgestern in hannau die haben gestern drüber bericht vorgestern
war das da war ein riesen aufgebot am hauptbahnhof irgendein typ ist mit der axt durch den bus
gerannt und in der heutigen zeit weißt du ja nie was da so abgeht jetzt wenn da einer
mit der axt in den bus steigt zumindest ist es alles klimpflich ausgegangen der 37 jahre
fack der typ so alt wie ich es ist gut ausgegangen er hat keinen verletzt und die haben den typ
festgenommen war das jetzt eine richtige axt oder nur so ein beil ja keine ahnung gibt
kein bild von der axt man steigt mit axt in linienbus und schreit fahrgäste tja sck
einsatz in hannau alter guckt euch das mal an um die ecke bei mir vielleicht hatte er
die axt auch nur dabei weil im bus die die diese scheiben einschlag hemer prinzipiell
immer nicht da sind vielleicht war es auch vielleicht war da auch beim baumarkt um die
und war doch auf dem weg heim aber dann schreit man die fahrgäste im bus nicht an so leute
wir müssen noch sortieren die to do's müssen sortiert werden so deswegen mal jetzt alert
let sorted nicht sorted sorted alerts nennen wir das jetzt oder wie sortieren wir das jetzt
überhaupt am besten ne ne ne ne ne ist falsch manchmal ist falsch manchmal wir sortieren
das hier drinnen ne machen wir nicht wir waren aber richtig manchmal wir machen hier sorted
alerts ich mach doch jetzt kein eigenes ich brauche ja mir kein eigenes sort ich mach
neben irgendwas fertiges doch du hast recht kraft ql kann sortieren aber ich will es
kleinzeitig sortieren aber kraft ql kann auch sortieren kraft ql kann auch sogar super page
naiten oder wie das heißt wisst ihr was mir unten schaltflächen und so page naiten page
naiten page naiten also wir sortieren wir sortieren ok ok wir sortieren also wir machen
ein reactive ein reactive spell magic ding wenn sich also wir füllen sorted alerts wenn
sich alerts data wir müssen erstmal checken ob alerts data das kann jetzt sein dass das
echt eklig ist wie wie ich das mache aber ich bin mir nicht sicher wie es anders machen
soll wir lassen das in ruhe return outside of function ok dann ja da bin ich mir jetzt
echt nicht sicher if alerts data dann sagen wir jetzt alerts data das kopieren wir uns
einmal ich hoffe dass ich hoffe dass funsta let data data sort ne wie war das sortieren
ja was gesort kann ich jetzt sorted alerts nehmen uns das ok ok alles klar so und wie
sortiere ich den kram jetzt ich sortiere das nach ich will das ich will das sortieren nach
start datum standardmäßig ok 5 hat 5 hat time wir sortieren wir sortieren den kram
also wir wollen sortieren nach start datum nach alert name und nach source also machen
wir mal sowas hier function sort bei nennt es mal irgendwie start kommt ja ne boah ich
bin verwirrt wie sortiere ich javascript arrays sortieren ist pains champ hoch 10 underscore
hat so ne funktion um das nach dem property zu sortieren aber ich will kein underscore
hier das ist die beste seite beste seite you don't need underscore sort bei da stehen
immer beispiele wie man das zeug mit echtem javascript macht ohne zusatz shit hier komm
mal sort key return a b a key größer b key 1 b key größer a key 1 excellent das will
ich haben das wusste war mir die ganze zeit schon klar dass ich das brauche aber jetzt
wo ich sehe easy es ist tatsächlich relativ easy es sieht erstmal nur kompliziert aus
das ding gibt kein wert zurück sondern ne funktion und die guckt erstes also erstes
array den key ist der größer als zweites array den key dann ist es eins was eins was
bei sortieren größer bedeutet dann ansonsten dreht das um und sagt es ist kleiner und ansonsten
ist es gleich das ist tatsächlich relativ einfach ok sort by start also wie machen wir
das denn jetzt nochmal also sorted alerts gleich
sekunde das mache ich hier rein oder das mache ich hier das machen gar nicht das kommt
erstmal weg sort alerts data sort geht trotzdem einfacher echt wie denn so ich will dass es
nicht kopiert sort und jetzt sort by a key started at das funzt das funzt es geht einfach
es funktioniert einfach guck mal es ist es ist es ist aufsteigend oder absteigend wie
nennt man das nie aufsteigen nach datum sortiert jetzt so wir sollten jetzt vielleicht nicht
alle alle alle 30 sekunden reicht glaube ich er die aus aus
guck mal es ist aufsteigend sortiert seht ihr es fängt 16 16 25 an 24 100 auf 25 das
ist richtig das sortiert nach datum park jam funktioniert ok das tatsächlich jetzt relativ
easy gewesen so nächste herausforderung wird es per click sortieren sortierbar machen muss
andersrum ja das ist richtig man sollte mit dem neuesten anfangen nicht mit dem ältesten
das ist schon das ist schon wahr ja ja ja also ich war wir können es einfach vertauschen
keck weit jetzt ist richtig rum easy wobei das funktioniert nicht wir müssen da funktion
übergeben weil ich will ja später auf click umschalten können also da brauchen wir sowas
hier wie keine ahnung desk ask oder sowas wie nennt man das direction oder so einfach
desk so also sprich wenn es so rum sein soll dann so und wenn es andersrum ist dann so
korrekt anscheinend sort mode mehr true falls reicht sollte da nicht sort by ascending sort
bei des desending hin das ist eine gute idee das könnte man natürlich auch machen wobei
ich das hier mit dem true fall falls um schalter ganz praktisch finde weil später will ich
ja mit einem click hin und her schalten dann erspare ich mir vielleicht ein paar ifs
die fallt die fallt ist falls oder ach nee moment das ist ja javascript so es sollte
übrigens nicht dessen so eine ascending heißen weil sonst ist es falsch rum oder ja weil
jetzt ist es jetzt ist es ascending falls was die sending true ist und die sending true
bedeutet ja es fängt mit dem großen an und geht zum kleinen oder egal so das funst das
wird automatisch sortiert warum die syntag so gleich aussieht denn das liegt aber jetzt
nur an dieser einen zeile in rust macht man ja auch gerne funktionale geschichten du findest
die fallt also findest es so rum intuitiver ja aber ich will das als die fallt nicht so
haben ich meine ich kann jetzt einfach das übergeben ich kann einfach sagen sort bei
und dann kann ich ihr sagen falls und dann ist es wieder richtig rum so wunderbar gut
jetzt sortiert er den kram schon mal nach zeit standardmäßig sobald sich updated das
kann ich aber auch einfacher haben da brauche ich dieses reactiv ding hier gar nicht das
kann ich deutlich einfacher haben ne kann ich kann ich kann ich nicht doch kann ich
kann ich nicht ich kann das doch hier drinne setzen sorted alerts ich du törner einfach
nix törner einfach nix easy data auch brauchen leute brauchen es ist broken also es ist auch
data alerts aha easy das sind wir kevin windows kevin ist down disk usage rip nicht kevin
leute jetzt hat's kevin auch noch erwischt ach nee kelvin noch schlimmer ok das das
finde ich das finde ich nice ich meine es ist doch es ist mein es ist hardcore unlesbar
oder schon ein bisschen sehr wir dann dann machen wir doch wirklich noch mal eine function
aus sort bei start könnte man das ganze nennen so data data und dann kommt der ganze füll
hier rein das kommt da rein sort bei data alerts also sort bei alerts
so geht sort sort bei erscheint mir fragwürdig ja wie willst du es sonst
machen es gibt ja nichts anderes das einzubringen
ist nichts eingebautes auf dem array das zu machen wenn du statt einer referenz eine
kopie übergeben willst kannst du auch data alerts machen nee in dem fall ist es ok weil
ich brauche dieses alerts in nirgendwo ich brauche am endeffekt nur nur sorted nur sorted
alerts glaube ich zumindest ich bin mir da selbst noch nicht so ganz sicher ob ich nur
sort also kann ich den krempel nehme ich eigentlich auch hier rein packen ins if dass ich nicht
oft blöde ideen komme ja nice nice array prototype sort bei das ist richtig wir könnten
array irgendwie extenden oder so das macht aber glaub auch nicht gerade klarer ok sort
bei start haben wir jetzt hier sondern brauche noch sort bei wir machen was anders moment
sort bei start ist das jetzt eigentlich den date unter der haube oder ist das ein string
unter der haube wahrscheinlich ist es ein string unter der haube und es gibt probleme
wenn ich gleiche gleiche zeit hätte
redicke ich jetzt einfach mal ok dann machen wir noch sort bei alert wenn ich alerts sorten
ne name name heißt das hier glaube ich wird ja vielleicht bisschen unglücklich benannt
so und dann haben wir noch sort bei source das habe ich tatsächlich source genannt vielleicht
soll ich das vielleicht soll ich das gleich nennen auf beiden seiten weil niemand denkt
auch da dran dass das hier name heißt stimmt ich kann ich kann den date draus machen das
probieren wir mal aus ob ich auch nach alert sortieren kann dem ich hier einfach sagen
sort bei alert funst guck mal es ist bei alert gesortet sort bei source
funst nice aber standardmäßig solls ja bei start sortiert sein ok und jetzt jetzt kommt
noch was trickreiches ich will hier oben draufklicken und dann soll er sortieren
also die einfache variante davon ist ja ich sag ihm hier einfach on click ach ne moment
eh click nicht on click warte mal es ist welt wie ging das jetzt bind click ne einfach nur
click oder einfach nur click ist es on click ja on click und jetzt hier den den kram sort
bei start sort bei alert und sort bei source so von der theorie her sollte is not a function
warum weil ich es nicht übergebe moment dann brauche ich alerts doch dann muss ich alerts
doch da oben drin
warte mal warte mal jetzt bin ich verwirrt jetzt bin ich gerade wie machen wir das jetzt
wir übergeben das nicht übergeben das nicht sondern wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt
hier erstmal gar nix return data alerts
moment ist es jetzt undy feind
warte mal ich blick nicht durch mach ich das gerade falsch ich bin schon zu lange am start
was mache ich denn falsch leute
also das muss weg das muss weg weil das nimmt er das da oben moment es ist dollar es ist
an der stelle da es ist ja es ist ja auch nicht es ist data dann weil es ist ja der
store jetzt jaja es ist der store und return
aha wir sehen dass wir nicht sehen was ganz gut ist weil es gibt keine fehler
ha leute guck mal das sortieren funktioniert wenn ich da oben drauf klicke seht ihr das
je nachdem wo ich drauf klicke sortiert er richtig das um schalten funktioniert er nicht
aber das sortieren funktioniert das ist nice und wie sage ich ihm jetzt dass er das einmal
initial machen soll beim beim empfang neuer daten und nicht erst beim klick dann sage
ich ihm das muss ich ok das muss ich dann reactiv machen da muss ich dann sagen quasi
wie war das dollar so
sort
but by starts das oder was
im subscrib also du meinst quasi so hier drin oder was das ist das mega das doch total umständlich
oder data das doch brutal umständlich oder nicht na gut ich mein im craft ql subscrib
ne im craft ql subscrib funktioniert nicht weil der craft ql subscrib ist ja dafür zuständig
dass data überhaupt gesetzt wird ich müsste es returnen ich müsste es returnen und danach
noch was machen was ich ja nicht kann das ist das ist nicht schön data sort bei wir
mein wir probieren es mal so aus jetzt start mal ok das funktioniert ok es ist zwar eklig aber es
funst so und das sorten funktioniert auch ich lasse es jetzt erst mal so damit es damit es
überhaupt funktioniert so und jetzt will ich ja hin und her schalten können also jetzt brauche
ich jetzt brauche ich ja quasi noch so was wie dass er sich merkt ob die suche aufsteigend oder
absteigend ist also quasi so was wie led sort bei ask ist standardmäßig falls oder true oder was
auch immer ist ja egal so und das muss ich umschalten jedes mal wenn ich da drauf klicke
ok ob das funktioniert das funktionieren ich habe ja da so meine zweifel ich meine an der
stelle sollte es funktionieren guck mal jetzt kann ich hin und her schalten
als funktioniert nicht überall gehen deine sortierfunktion erst noch einmal
du meinst dass ich das hier gar nicht mehr brauche sondern das direkt hier drin verwenden
ja stimmt warum eigentlich nicht machen wir im header so ein feil ja das machen wir dann ich
lasse jetzt erstmal den kram von dem ich weiß dass er funktioniert in ruhe ok kommt mal das
hin und her schalten funst jetzt kann ich sortieren pochchamp wir müssen aber doch
eine sachen im header machen dass das gescheit funktioniert und zwar keine kursor events
oder keine nicht keine kursor keine select select nun ja viel besser so und kursor pointer guckt
dass man auch weiß dass man was zum anklicken hat viel besser oder viel besser so jetzt kann
ich den shit sortieren leute was haltet ihr davon leute ich habe die massive absolut feifheder idee
wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen massive feifett ihr werdet ihr werdet staunen wie feifett ist
jetzt ist gleich aus was massivster feifett kommt mal passt mal auf passt mal auf was haltet ihr
davon wenn wir anstatt die zeit so reinzuschreiben wenn wir da reinschreiben 5 minutes ago und so
was so viel das doch viel besser date fns leute also wenn das das agiler ja ich warte auf die
reaktion im chat das ist massive feifett eigentlich viel viel viel viel viel besser
next level shit installation was ist das eigentlich für eine hässliche seite flashback install
noch 5 und 6 hettiger eigentlich schon 11 hätte reichen 5 5 widget kopfnet mehr ausführen
so passt passt mal auf guckt euch das jetzt mal an so wir machen jetzt wenn man draufklickt
ändert es sich von datum auf satz auch eine sehr gute idee ich hätte jetzt eigentlich an tooltips
gedacht oder so aber standardmäßig gucken wir uns das erstmal anderweitig an scheinbar sich
gucken wir erstmal wie man das format format time oder irgendwie sowas
function function format time so und jetzt brauchen wir hier distance hieß der kram distance distance
ist dann ist distanz distanz now require cacquade was sind wir denn hier mit dem jahr 2022 zack
distanz beispiel in about genau das will ich haben
format time bem return ja ja date time so distance to now und jetzt passt auf jetzt
wirds richtig messer voll fett format time bem guckt euch das mal an ich 11 hätte alter
11 hat 26 hätte das ist geil das gefällt mir poggers das ist viel lesbarer als dieser komische
scheiß timestamp und der nord benutzt man wie quai es ist ja auch kein nord ist ja alles im
browser und im browser kannst du mittlerweile auch sagt glaube ich zwei java script version
oder so diese diese module syntax nehmen ich habe ich habe einen fehler in meiner logik
beim neuen abrufen ändert er das da das muss das muss ich mir da muss ich mir noch was
überlegen dass er das nicht mal aber das ist geil das ist nice eigentlich braucht man das
nicht mehr was denn du meinst weil es jetzt seit der letzten version irgendwelche neuen
time ap skippt was wird das überhaupt das ist ein fake monitoring system was fake werte
ausspuckt mir geht es rein ums üben von swell plus craft ql also dass das ist automatisch
switched muss ich mir noch was überlegen das ist nicht so clever nicht so clever gelöst
aber guckt mal es funst überall und ich kann das hier umschalten das hier umschalten das
ist gut so warum jetzt noch feile hin machen leute warum jetzt noch feile hin machen dass
der zeigt in welche richtung er gerade ordered ändert sich die zeitangabe auch automatisch
ja das ist ja tunau das sollte sich automatisch ändern jedes mal wenn es updated jaja ok was
es nicht macht ist wahrscheinlich wenn es sich nicht update das render der nur einmal
ja das ist ein guter das ist richtig das macht er ja gar nicht also hier ist ja es ist datetime
render only also das ist wenn es einmal wenn es einmal gerendert ist dann bleibt es da
stehen bis zum nächsten update ja da muss man sich noch was überlegen ja das stimmt
das ist das richtig aber das finde ich schon mal äußerst nice jetzt jetzt ok jetzt kommt
jetzt kommt der nächste feifert nächste feifert geschichte tooltips tooltips da habe ich was
da habe ich was cooles gelesen github tailwind tooltips da gab es eine ganz easy variante
wie man tooltips enttäglich machen kann ob das hier genau man musste einfach nur das
da hinzufügen zu seiner zu seinem css und das war es mehr hat man nicht gebraucht und
jetzt konnte man sagen tooltip jetzt konnte man einfach sagen dass da tooltips am start
heute urlaub ich bin immer noch krank musste heute nicht arbeiten
und da kommt jetzt nicht so ein nice tooltip text rein sondern new date new date alert start
what the fuck new local string guck mal und schon habe ich ein nice overlay was natürlich
kacke aussieht wo ich mir noch was anderes überlegen muss tooltip rounded shadow shadow
ist ok padding ist auch ok mal mal zweier padding die farben müssen anders sein die
farben müssen anders sagt so das ist das ist müll text ist mir auch zu groß text ist
will ich in klein haben und was weiß ich den den den background mal mal bg gray ich 700
oder so hey leute da können wir nix sagen also das ist ein wirklich professional looking
tooltip da kann man jetzt echt nix sagen gegen professioneller tooltip hier guckt euch das
mal an massive tooltip aber noch zwei pixel nach oben warum pointer events müssen wir
ausmachen pointer non perfekt klebt so am text ja ok minus minus 9 minus 10 so besser wir
können das übrigens noch noch ein bisschen weiter nach links machen so ist glaube ich
noch besser oder oder vielleicht sogar noch vielleicht vier so ich habe keine ahnung
aus dem kopf was date plus prozent c was da rauskommt welches der 30 milliarden formats
das ist wir müssen mal ein bisschen was länger als 24 stunden ago wir brauchen wir brauchen
nicht date recent in days genau den in den letzten 30 tagen letzten 30 tage der rübel
dankeschön für den sub massive subscription hier du verkaufst das jetzt deinem chef für
3k für 3k kriegen die bei mir nix eigentlich nur das kann ja offen bleiben 3k ist im enterprise
umfeld ja gar nix hat dort net kein hot reload doch aber das macht komische dinger guck mal
das funst jetzt haben wir hier verteilt bis 30 tage ago wir können übrigens noch mal
wir machen moment wir machen das noch mal wir machen das mal auf wir machen das mal
auf 60 tage oder auf 61 und gucken ob dann was von zwei monaten und so steht also ob
es dann von tage auf monate wechselt ja guck mal about one hour ago geht bis zu two months
ago wie war eigentlich deine präsentation am montag zu schitt zu schitt tritt außer
dass ich gehustet habe während der präsentation muss gar ein zahlbein baumann futtern war das
eigentlich ganz ok wir hatten sehr wenig vorbereitungszeit weil ich habe die mit
jemand anderem zusammen gehalten wir waren kaum zusammen da wir haben es quasi letzte
woche freitag uns ausgedacht und montag dann gehalten war ganz ok und die meisten sachen
wurden quasi auch mehr oder weniger eins zu eins so so aufgenommen und auch die ansichten
mehr oder weniger geteilt ja dass es da probleme gibt was programmierst du ein fake monitoring
tool weil ich swelt und craftql üben will nice aber das funktioniert das finde ich
nice guck mal der tooltip funktioniert auch also der tooltip ist das das ist wirklich
nochmal hier so richtig exquisite tooltip obendrauf so was soll leute was soll eigentlich
passieren war doofe frage was passiert denn wenn man jetzt auf so einen eintrag draufklickt
das mache ich heute nicht sage ich gleich dazu aber es wäre denn eure ansicht nach
etwas sinnvolles was passiert wenn man auf den ein wenn man auf so einen monitoring eintrag
draufklickt mehr infos oder da müsste ein popup aufgehen oder einen slider aufgehen wo
mehr infos dazu drinne stehen slider oder popup was meint ihr ist besser also
slider würde quasi diese zwei elemente also das hier runter slide und dann einzeigen slider
oder pop up slider was spricht bei euch für einen slider und gegen ein popup dann kann
man mehrere öffnen six hat genau leider ist tatsächlich wenn du aber du willst ja
eigentlich mehrere öffnen ich tendiere fast fast so popup aber das machen wir heute nicht
sage ich auch gleich dabei habe ich nur überlegt ja gut temperatur den wert kann ich ja nur
wenn sie mir die api zurückliefern aktuell gibt es da kein wert dazu das karl backup
ist da und die willfried die willfried blockchain pc lustig das geht nicht weil
heutzutage muss man an mobile bedienung denken und mobile bedienung hat ja keine mittlere
mauskaste die kommen aus faker oder aus bogus in dem fall das sind random generated domain
namen ja hier muss ich mir jetzt noch mal ach so feile wollte ich ja noch rein machen
hiero eikens also das ist bei dem refresh das ist bei dem refresh das überschreibt
ist ziemlich ziemlich doof kann ich nicht hier einfach die sachen selbst setzen kann
ich mir nicht das da ich ich mache das jetzt vor sort bei start
jetzt sollte es
um geht es jetzt nicht mehr
ach weil ich hier nichts retorne ah man alda das ist aber echt das ist aber echt feifett
das habe ich das da muss ich mir da muss ich was anderes überlegen das ist nicht schön
was ich hier mache aber jetzt sollte ich zumindest das problem gefixt haben dass es beim updaten
nach oben springt aber da muss ich mir was anderes überdenken wenn das für mobile ausgelegt
sein soll möchte ich auch haben dass man den eintrag wegwischen kann zum acknowledge
oah poggers alda jetzt wirds aber advanced wir machen wir machen noch wir machen noch
eikens oben hin ja ok das sortieren bleibt jetzt gleich ok sort sort ascending sort descending
so wo kommen denn diese eikens jetzt hin eigentlich könnte man da mal eine neue komponente für
machen weil es wird schon ganz schön voll
wir machen jetzt eine neue komponente für holder lib file sort eiken
oh Mist sorteigen dafür kann man sich bestimmt überschreiten ob sich da lohnt eine eigene
komponente für zu machen aber why not das gibt ja noch zwei sort eikens eins eins für
so rum und eins für andersrum sortiert
top lip musste man das nennen was welt sort eiken was kriegt denn sort eiken für properties
soll mit dem minus macht man das nicht so wie macht man das sonst ach alex das wusste
ich nicht schreibt man das einfach zusammen ohne minus
also sprich ich sollte die dinger dann
warum kann ich es nicht umbenennen wo ist mein remake wo ist mein rename knopf
Leute wo ist der remake ach hier ich bin auch falsch da rename so also eigentlich sollte
ich so nennen oder wie sort eiken
mit großem s aber warum ist index dann klein geschrieben standardmäßig
sollte nicht index dann auch großes e haben am anfang also let export
export let ja welche reinfolge wie das wie das wie das angeordnet sein soll und export
let ob es überhaupt angezeigt werden soll weil wir wollen ja nicht überall eikens haben
so das ist das hero eiken für ascending da braucht das hero eiken für die sending und
dann müssen wir ihm sagen if ascending das und die sending das moment also das muss ich
sagen diese sonntags da werde ich mich nie dran gewöhnen das ist das ist mal ein mal
ein hier einen raute ist mal gar nichts mal ein doppelpunkt und dann das wieder schließen
das ist schon komisch naja ok poggers sort eiken component am start dann werden wir die
mal einblenden hier jetzt sort eiken sort sort eiken wo ist es denn also ich muss es
erst mal importieren so import sort eiken mache ich das so richtig rom rom lip sort
eiken ist das korrekt was ich jetzt gemacht habe da steht einfach nur sort eiken warum
ach so weil ich nicht in den element da ist das sort eiken ist da guck mal sort bei guck
mal hier beim der switch sogar um guckt euch das mal wobei das ist bisschen schlecht platziert
oder bis also das sort eiken sollte schon lieber neben daneben dran also was macht man
jetzt einfach flex ja flex items end so space between
between das juckt das nicht space between ist dem egal dann das margin right zack
ist doch gut aber was justify betwen ok chat ich glaube ich glaube euch das ich glaube
ich das justify betwen ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne das sieht
nix aus so was besser oder wir lassen es jetzt mal so ok jetzt brauche ich natürlich das
sort eiken hier auch noch nur mit dem unterschied dass es hier ein alert ist wie finde es anders
besser wirklich oh jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich ich habe es kaputt gemacht leute monka
ich habe ich habe es kaputt gemacht lull ich habe irgendwas zerstört gerade das das
funktioniert nicht ok ich mache das mal wieder rückgängig das nicht so schön jetzt habe
ich nur noch das eiken da sonst gar nix auch nicht schlecht ok also chat jetzt ihr seid
ihr gefragt was ist was ist besser also das da das das da vielleicht soll ich so ein
bisschen kleiner machen leute ich mache das eiken kleiner das eiken ist auch eh zu groß
guck mal das eiken ist doch eh zu groß mal fünf ja das schon besser oder von der kürze
her ich würde table hat auch als component machen ja wahrscheinlich generell könnte
man die ganze data table als als dings man so ist das doch schon mal ein bisschen besser
also so so oder was hatten wir noch zur alternative wie gesagt das ganze kann ja auch sein dass
es so breit ist ansonsten hatten wir noch zur alternative also entweder so mit dem eiken
oder justify betwen oder so chat was besser so oder oder so so also
ok das muss ich jetzt natürlich für alle machen aber das würde ich sagen chat das
mal das nächste mal mir reicht jetzt drei stunden 45 proger stellt genug aber wir haben
heute tatsächlich ordentlich was geschafft und eins müsst ihr zugeben jetzt mal wirklich
chat ehrliche meinung von euch kein getrolle wobei ich ich ich vergesse ja manchmal wo
ich hier wo ich hier bin es sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus oder he doesn't know he lacks
critical information es sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus oder auch das sortieren hier
oben mit dem header und so zu eins ganz nice wenn du rounded machst bei den boxen du meinst
das hier wie macht man überhaupt rounded um ein table tr kann man das einfach hier
reinschreiben kann man ja einfach sagen rounded natürlich nett das muss man bestimmt mit
border machen border border vor jetzt rounded nee kann man das geht das gar nicht kann
das sein dass man tr nicht rounded machen kann hier nicht rounded wie kriege ich das
jetzt rounded muss ich da noch ein diff rein machen du musst th rounded machen nee oder
wenn ich th rounded mache dann sieht es ja geht auch nicht aber das ist falsch das ist
falsch ich bin hier hier muss ich ein rounded das funktioniert an der stelle nicht stream
läuft oder falsche kategorie warum stimmt es gibt ja jetzt habe ich gar nicht daran
gedacht es wäre wahrscheinlich besser gewesen zum finden es gibt ja jetzt programming stellens
ja du hast recht habe ich gar nicht daran gedacht ich mein wirklich falsch ist das nicht
aber es ist wahrscheinlich zu finden besser wie mache ich wie mache ich in dieser zelle
wie mache ich jetzt rounded wie mache ich das jetzt rounded kann ich das td rounded machen
aber nur aber nur oben rounded nur nur oben rounded unten unten unten nicht richtig rounded
fake rounded g rounded fake rounded rounded x triple xl rounded ja td kann ich nicht rounded
machen und das tr geht nicht rounded da bin ich jetzt überfragt wie macht man das muss
ich da muss ich da jetzt noch ein extra diff drum machen muss ich da irgendwie noch ein
extra diff irgendwie hier dass ihr noch irgendwie ein extra diff drum machen nee nee das funktioniert
ja nicht oder um das komplette tr noch ein extra diff vielleicht also quasi so und dann
die color auch ok was tr round ok jetzt wird es jetzt wird high iq technisch ja ich sehe
schon rounded was nicht funktioniert und was overflow auf was hidden das interessierte
nicht die bone ob das rounded ist man sieht man sieht den border ja auch nicht warte mal
border so dass man ihn sieht ok der border ist weder weder rounded der border ist weder
rounded noch sonst was also das funktioniert an der stelle irgendwie nicht da ist nichts
rounded keine ahnung wie man das rund macht ok stack overflow tr rounded how to add border
radius on table row stack overflow was rounded tr so was gibt es wait a minute was nein das
ist top right das hat mit tr noch nichts zu tun das ist top right wie gesagt müsste es
die ganzen tedes links round und die letzte td recht also sporn nee oder das ist ja das
ist ja abartig also ich muss quasi die erste dann hier round und die hier dann hier round
oder wie also die erste runde ich links oben links unten und die letzte runde ich rechts
oben und rechts unten wie seriously no pass also nur mal von der idee um zu gucken ob das
wirklich funktioniert rounded xl einfach mal so rounded xl rounded top
als rounded top xl tatsächlich das müsst allen ernstes top right top top left
das ist aber schon bottom left das ist aber schon echt hardcore ppega das so zu machen
stimmt gibt es rounded left ja das schon triple triple ppega so und jetzt würde ich sagen
rounded right beim letzten ich weiß nicht also kann ich margin bottom 2 oder so machen
nee ich ein abstand dazwischen überhaupt sieht aber komisch aus
das fehlt da fehlt ein stückchen von unten wegen dem anderen border oder bin ich zu ppega
für das jetzt richtig hinzukriegen da gibt es nur den weg über borders ok findet ihr
dass es prinzipiell aber rounded besser aussieht oder viereckig ich meine vielleicht vielleicht
mal was nicht so fett wir machen es vielleicht nicht so fett wir machen einfach nur lg rounded
so aber ich muss sagen ich finde sogar eckig besser ich ein moderner mag es vielleicht
aussehen mit rounded ok wir machen wir machen einfach normal rounded ohne irgendwelche sperenzien
hier einfach nur rounded ja ok das muss ich sagen das finde ich das finde ich gut so so
leicht rounded wobei halt die sache ist der checkt unten ich guck mal der schneidet unten
aus irgendwelchen gründen ab da müsste man sich überlegen wie man das jetzt ordentlich
macht weil den border hier brauche ich ja für unten drunter keine ahnung es ist nur
oben rounded ja weil unten durch diesen border das hier überschrieben wird was dumm ist ja
guck wenn ich das hier weg mache ist überall gerundet aber dann habe ich kein spacing mehr
dazwischen kann ich nicht in spacing machen mit einer fake mit einer fake table row oder
so dass ich jetzt quasi sage klas border border 4 hey doch das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren
ne du würdest nicht mal tabel verwenden warum nicht ey das ist ja bescheuert alles es geht
trotzdem nicht panning ist gehen oft herr nicht richtig was break dazwischen nun komm
in den break funktionier das easy wir machen einfach den break dazwischen
ja den break dazwischen funktioniert es ist ja bescheuert was du sollst in deiner freizeit
ich geh wandern ab und zu mal und ansonsten bastel ich halt zum größten ich programmier
die dinger ich bastel hier daheim rum von heim automatisierung bis technik krams bin
eigentlich gut beschäftigt hier einfach ein diff drunter machen kann man da nicht einfach
ein diff drunter machen unter jedes einfach sagen klas margin top 2 easy fertig einfach
das ding drunter klatschen und gut ist eins oder zwei zwei oder weil margin oft weil margin
oft herr nicht funktioniert das sieht jetzt schon moderner aus ja nice ja gut das pack
noch ein bisschen hier an der stelle ja t-body darf nur trs enthalten laut hat der 5 speck
ist kein diff drin erlaubt das ist mir sowas von egal ob das lauter speck erlaubt ist oder
nicht das punkt mal gucken ob es im firefox funktioniert ja funktioniert auch also scheiß
auf speck es geht in firefox und chrome lass mich raten im safari geht es wahrscheinlich
nicht im zweifelsfall gehen sachen nie im safari wenn sie woanders funktionieren glaubt
du musst pro spalte einführen ja das vermute ich auch ich muss nicht ich muss vor allem
mir merken nach was ich sortiert habe ich muss mir merken nach was ich sortiert habe
weil wenn ich hier klicke soll ja nicht das hier hochgehen sondern das soll hier ein pfeil
kommen aber das da kann ich da kann ich mit leben das ist alles in ordnung und guckt
mal selbst selbst im fullscreen sieht das brauchbar aus
einfach im tr ein diff wrapen weiß nicht ob das funktioniert wenn das in der html 5 speck
auch drinne steht dass in einem td keine weiteren elemente top level sein dürfen oder irgendwie
sowas da steht da garantiert auch drinne wenn es schon für tr drin steht steht es im td
bestimmt auch drinne kann man wetten aber das interessiert sich noch nicht mal
ach nee das geht ja nicht ich will es ja außerhalb haben ich will es ja außerhalb haben den hier
bringt ja gar nichts wir müssen wir müssen es hier ins tr ins tr rein mal tt ober ins tr
ne das geht auch nicht ins tr geht geht ne ne ne geht hier gar nicht margin bottom muss
ich hier machen das bringt nichts das bringt nichts ich muss ich muss das mögliche unten
runter machen scheiß auf html 5 speck wenn interessiert es funktioniert weg
für tables gab es doch border collapse habe ich keinen plan von deswegen habe ich es jetzt
so gemacht es ist aber echt in ordnung also gerade ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen wenn
man das auf so einer wand hängen hat wie man wie man beispielsweise in irgendwelchen
network operation center und so den kram hat das würde man wirklich gut erkennen also
der kontrast ist in ordnung die schriftgröße ist ist in ordnung anhand der farbe erkennst
du sofort was abgeht ja das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool jetzt gehe ich aber echt was fuddern
schön dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid ich weiß proga streams gucken immer nicht ganz
so viele aber mit 200 zuschauen ist wirklich nice ich hoffe jetzt nachdem ein halbes wieder
ein bisschen besser ist dass ich öfter stream kann und ich muss mal endlich ein video machen
mein letztes video ist keine ahnung 14 tage her
sie lief das meeting am montag ja das lief ganz gut man hat das eigentlich mehr oder
weniger alles so geteilt
ja normalerweise guck mal sonntags bei den aufwachen streams sind teilweise 450 dabei
bei battlefield waren auch richtig viel dabei sogar als ich letztes mal da auch gestreamt
haben witzigerweise zwischendurch mal 400 aber ich weiß dass die leute unterschiedliche
geschmacker haben und ich mache ja hier in letzter zeit fast nur technik kram was auch
immer sehr beliebt ist sind die bastel videos letztens wo wir den den micro server wie heißt
das ding micro server gebaut haben das fanden die leute haben auch glaube ich bis zu 300
leute zugeguckt also leute ich geh jetzt was fuddern ich habe hunger pepo fett bis denn
wir sehen uns beim nächsten stream machts gut see you